Morgen Leute, oh man, eigentlich, oh ich bin übelst im Arsch, ne, ne noch nicht, warte
mal, warte mal, wup wup wup, ja ok, ne Runde wup wup wup, wup wup wup wup wup wup, ok, wup
wup wup, hoffentlich ist die Lautstärke passt, ja wup wup, wup wup, ähm, jetzt wollte
ich, ja nein, bin ich nicht, ey ich bin übelst im Arsch von der Runde Fahrradfahren gestern,
ich bin auch noch nicht Rennen gegangen, eigentlich wäre es dran gewesen, aber ich habe keinen
Bock heute, ey, aber eigentlich, also insgesamt muss ich sagen, ergänzt sich tatsächlich
Rennen und Fahrradfahren ganz gut, Fahrradfahren merke ich hauptsächlich in Oberschenkel und
teilweise Hände, wenn ich zu lang drauf gesessen habe und Rennen eher so Schienenbeine, also
ergänzt sich tatsächlich ganz gut, vielleicht gehe ich nachher noch, aber wahrscheinlich
mache ich eher mal einen Tag Pause jetzt, ne, wie gesagt, ich war noch nicht wählen,
ich gehe wahrscheinlich heute Mittag irgendwann, ist ja auch nicht weit weg, dauert keine Ahnung,
5 Minuten bin ich da, fällt mir ein, es war doch in irgendeiner, ich glaube es war nicht,
es war irgendeine Bürgermeisterwahl oder sowas, war doch vor nicht allzu langer Zeit,
gab es doch da in irgendeiner Gemeinde oder so, haben die Bürgermeister gewählt oder
Landrat oder irgendwas, keine Ahnung und da hat im Wahlbüro irgendjemand gefragt, hat gefragt,
wie ist das eigentlich, muss ich meinen Wahlzettel unterschreiben und da hat irgendein Wahlhelfer,
so just for fun gesagt, aus Spaß, na klar, immer unterschreiben, da hat der Kerl unterschrieben und
am Ende war die komplette Wahl da ungültig, tja, da muss man aufpassen mit irgendwelchen blöden
Sprüchen, je nachdem mit welcher Rolle man gerade unterwegs ist, ich muss kurz nochmal was nehmen
hier, hast du mitbekommen, dass Google wohl bei dir in der Nähe ein RZ bauen will, Google will
nicht, Google hat gebaut, Google Rechenzentrum Wolfgang ist das, ja in Hanau gibt es in den
Stadtteilen heißt es wirklich Wolfgang, wie der Vorname, keine Ahnung, ja die GoPro ist da,
guck hier, guck das ist bei mir, also es ist nicht direkt um die Ecke, aber es ist nicht
sonderlich weit weg, Google eröffnet Rechenzentrum, gibt es das Ganze vielleicht noch mit Darkreader
irgendwie, dass ich nicht so extrem geblendet werde, ja, warum Google ein Cloud Rechenzentrum
in Deutschland eröffnet, was ist das für eine bescheuerte Überschrift, Google hat schon einige
Rechenzentren in Deutschland und Standorte in Deutschland, ich meine das ist jetzt nicht als
wäre das was super noch nie dagewesenes, Pionierarbeit, Neues, es ist halt ein weiteres Rechenzentrum, ja
Internetknotenpunkt in der Nachbarschaft, da gibt es, gibt es in Frankfurt, ich weiß nicht ob der
Dezix nur in Frankfurt ist, aber ich glaube es gibt mindestens zwei Standorte, der größte ist auf der
Hanauer Landstraße, aber gibt ja, gibt ja noch mehr, ja, hier steht auch noch Dezix, ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass
man das Dezix ausspricht, aber letztens im, im Radio war das glaube ich, haben die gesagt,
haben die gesagt Dekix, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich keine Ahnung habe oder der Typ, der
den Beitrag ausgesprochen hat, keine Ahnung hat, Leute ist es Dezix oder Dekix, ich glaube es ist
Dezix, ich weiß gar nicht wofür da steht, Exchange oder sowas, ja, das weiß ich, das ist, ich bin, ich bin
mir gar nicht so sicher, wo das ist, ich glaube, dass es dort ist, wo früher die Ami-Kaserne war,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob man weiß, wo das genau ist, ja, das ist, das ist glaube ich dort, wo die, wo die
Ami-Kaserne früher gewesen ist, ja, nee, aber hier ist nicht das Cloud-Rechenzentrum, die Ami-Kaserne
war hier irgendwo früher, glaube ich, hier, hier, hier und ich dachte, hier irgendwo ist jetzt das
Rechenzentrum, naja, was auch immer, mal ganz davon abgesehen, für mich eh vollkommen irrelevant, weil
es ist jetzt nicht so, als gibt es da super interessante Jobs im Rechenzentrum selbst, keine
Daten von Privatmenschen, das halte ich mal für ein Gerücht, es ist jetzt, es ist jetzt sicherlich
nicht so, dass dort die Google Drive Sachen gehostet werden, zum größten Teil, aber selbstverständlich
werden dort und sei es auch nur über Umwege von irgendeinem Anbieter, der sich dort was gemietet
hat, Sachen von Privatmenschen liegen. Referenzkunden sind die Commerzbank, der Automobilzulieferer,
Fahrer, Fährer, Fährer, Fahrer und Lufthansa, okay, naja, ist auch gut, ja, also ich finde, ich finde das
gut, mich wundert ja, mich wundert ja, dass es überhaupt gebaut werden konnte und das nicht auf
den letzten Drückern auch irgendwie festgestellt wurde, dass da irgendwie seltene Froscharten nistet
oder so, weil nisten Frösche, seltene Vogelarten nistet und keine Möglichkeit gibt, das Rechenzentrum
zu bauen. Es ist übrigens nicht der einzige Standort, ich glaube, es gibt bei uns in Hanau jetzt noch ein
weiteres Rechenzentrum und zwar dort, wo aktuell das, dieses, das provisorische Flüchtling, die
provisorische Flüchtlingsunterkunft ist in Hanau, wird daneben ein Rechenzentrum gebaut, das ist
wie heißt denn die Ecke, mal kurz Maps aufmachen, hier unten ist das, bin verwirrt, ist denn was, ja,
Moment, ich probier mal kurz, hier irgendwo glaube ich, ich glaube hier, glaube hier entsteht auch
gerade ein Rechenzentrum hier irgendwo. Nein, ich suche nichts Neues, es wäre ja nicht verkehrt,
was direkt um die Ecke zu haben. Ich glaube, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, von wo es losgeht,
es könnte, es könnte auch hier schon sein, also hier irgendwie entsteht, glaube ich, auch gerade
ein Rechenzentrum. Hier ist, soweit ich weiß, die, zumindest in Großarmen, diese provisorische
Flüchtlingsunterkunft irgendwo, das sieht man daran, weil hier vorne alles voller Security-Leute
steht, es war früher so ein Ami-Checkpoint hier, da weiß ich noch, bei, nach 9-11 standen hier,
standen sie hier mit, mit M16, M4s rum am Eingang und Sandsäcken, hatten sie hier, das war das erste
Mal, dass ich außerhalb von Games bewaffnete Soldaten mit, mit Gewehren gesehen habe, da
standen sie hier mit, mit, mit, mit M16 rum und hier vorne, hier vorne in diesem Häuschen hockte
einer mit Sandsäcken und einem, was weiß ich, was, was ich, was das gewesen ist, M60 oder irgendwie
sowas, keine Ahnung, mit einem MG rum, als kämen jetzt hier die Terroristen in Großauheim. Naja,
zumindest seit ein paar Jahren ist das ja leer, das sind die Amis, sind ja alle weg hier, das war
früher hier alles Kaserne, ich glaube sogar, dass hier unten war noch Kaserne, vielleicht war das
hier theoretisch sogar mal ein Landeplatz oder so, auf jeden Fall waren viele Amis hier in Hanau
unterwegs, aber die sind schon zu 95% alle weg. Bietet sich an, auf solchen Stellen Rechenzentren
oder generell solche sowas zu bauen, weil es ist halt einfach viel ungenutzte Fläche, auf einem
anderen Kasernengebiet haben sie jetzt eine Siedlung gebaut, da hast du recht, ja. Ja, ja,
die GoPro ist da, ich muss mir noch eine Halterung, entweder bestelle ich mir eine Halterung bei
Amazon oder ich 3D-Druck mir eine Halterung selbst für den Lenker. Straßennamen sind generell
pippiger und wie gesagt, nein, ich suche nichts Neues, aber es wäre doch cool, wenn Google irgendwas
um die Ecke eröffnet und dann gäbe es irgendwas Interessantes. Nicht, dass ich wirklich scharf
drauf bin, ehrlich gesagt bin ich überhaupt nicht scharf drauf für Google zu arbeiten, auch nicht
für Amazon oder Microsoft, aber es wäre zumindest mal interessant, wenn es in der Nähe was gäbe
und es da tatsächlich coole Jobs gibt. Man ist ja mit seinem Arbeitgeber nicht verheiratet, also
wenn es sich da was anderes ergibt oder mir irgendwas auf den Keks geht, schläße ich das
nicht aus. Aktuell sieht es halt gar nicht so aus, jetzt nicht falsch verstehen, aktuell finde ich es
wirklich nice. Wenn Google nicht so viel bezahlt, dann gehe ich da auch nicht hin, ist ganz einfach.
Gewisses Niveau muss dann schon gehalten werden. Ach, den graben die nicht umsonst für 15 Jahre,
da muss ein bisschen Kohle bei rumkommen. Ich konnte heute Nacht gar nicht richtig pennen,
Leute, weil mir beim Umdrehen, haben mir immer, wenn ich mich umdrehen wollte, da braucht man die
Hände zu zum Umdrehen, hat mir immer, wenn ich auf die Hände gedrückt habe am Umdrehen, die Hände
wehgetan an der Seite und ich hatte auch permanent so im Oberschenkel immer so ein bisschen noch
Druck. Also das habe ich gestern glaube ich echt ein bisschen übertrieben, ich bin es halt einfach
nicht gewohnt. Insgesamt sind 50 oder 51 Kilometer jetzt sicherlich jetzt nicht mega viel, gibt ja
Leute, die fahren am Tag irgendwie 100 plus, aber für mich ist es viel und die Strecke ist es gar
nicht, was mich gekillt hat, der Berg hat mich gekillt. Also auf dem Hinweg und so überhaupt
kein Problem, aber auf dem Rückweg, ihr seht ja, manchmal sind so kleine Huppeln noch drin,
da muss man mal eine Brücke hoch und einen kleinen Anstieg hoch, Leute, das war brutal,
nachdem ich den Berg hochgefahren bin, diese kleinen Anstieg, da war ich immer mega kaputt
danach gleich. Die Heartrate ist nicht, naja, durchschnittlich. Guck mal, hier hoch war die
nicht niedrig, hier war die niedrig, halbwegs, hier war die wieder niedrig, aber hier war die
heftig. Das ist nicht der Feldberg, nein, das ist nicht der Feldberg, das ist, ja da ist das,
hier bin ich hochgefahren. Übrigens, ich habe mal gestern euren Tipp befolgt, mal in Apple,
da gibt es jede Menge Trails, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob es dort irgendwie ein Rennen gibt,
aber den Namen für Berge gibt es einige, es gibt nicht nur den, also es gibt auch welche,
die sind über 2000 Meter hoch und heißen so. Ja, Pog, was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen? Ich
wollte gerade irgendwas, ja, Blobs und Ascherdangische für den Sub, genau, mit 40
dann, nee. Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen? Irgendwie habe ich mich voll verdrängt,
keine Ahnung, ja, kann ich mir vorstellen. Ich glaube, da ist vieles Gewöhnungssache und auch
gerade sowas, was Rücken und so angeht. Ich habe ja keine Rückenprobleme, was ich gut finde,
die meisten Leute schreiben mir irgendwas von Rückenproblemen, gar nichts, vielleicht habe
ich mein Fahrrad doch halbwegs gescheit eingestellt, zumindest auf den Händen merke
ich es halt immer noch, dass ziemlich viel Druck drauf ist. YouTube Beef beigelegt,
gibt es ja nichts großartig, gibt es ja nicht wirklich irgendwas beizulegen,
gab ja gar nicht so richtig Beef. Also ich habe das Video von Golo geguckt und jetzt verstehe ich
das auch, ja, ich wusste ja nicht, dass das so halbes Kindheitstrauma ist, mit den Augen. Ich
dachte, es ist eher auf dem Niveau von der Max hat dicke Arme, so lacht man mal drüber und dann
ist gut. Wer sich noch daran erinnert, das war ja auch eine Zeit lang bei mir auf YouTube,
das fand ich jetzt auch nicht schlimm, aber klar, dann ist das was anderes. Hätte ich auch
nicht erzählt, hätte ich das gewusst. Dann lasst uns doch mal gucken. Ich mache das hier mal alles
zu. Stimmt, für HelloFresh mache ich ja vielleicht auch Werbung. Mal gucken. Wo ist ShitHub? Hier,
ne, wo bloß? GitHub Trends Weekly, das wollte ich angucken. Lass uns doch mal gucken,
was händelt. Microsoft Autogen oder Autogen, ach ne, ach das ist AI gedöhnt. Ich dachte,
da geht es um irgendwelche Language Bindings oder Code Generation für .NET, irgendwas ganz was
anderes, AI Zeug. Na gut, warum hätte das sonst auch so viele Sterne? Leute, ich habe schon fast
über ein Kilo abgenommen. Oder eigentlich habe ich schon eher eineinhalb Kilo abgenommen,
seit ich angefangen habe Fahrrad zu fahren. Das ist jetzt morgens eigentlich immer eine ganze Ecke
unter 92, ohne dass ich irgendwas mache. Letztens sogar mal fast unter 90, aber das war auch Absicht,
da bin ich nach dem Fahren so komplett nur mit Unterhose auf die Waage gestellt. Wobei das
stimmt nicht, es war nicht unter 90, es war 90,2 oder so. Also es bringt was. Man muss sagen,
die Kalorienberechnung, was man verbraucht von Garmin, scheint mir aber ein wenig pp-iger zu
sein. Gestern war Garmin der Meinung, ich habe 1400 Kalorien verbraucht in drei Stunden. Das
erscheint mir ein bisschen viel, weil es ist quasi die Hälfte von meinem Tagesbedarf. Vielleicht
ein bisschen viel, aber es hat auf jeden Fall ordentlich was verbraucht. Ganz so viel bezweifle
ich dann doch ein bisschen. Mittagessen ist zumindest wieder weg. Was ist das? China-Chinesen
zu euch? Okay, keine Ahnung. Ist das sowas wie Firebase? Doch, Firebase. Ich wollte gerade sagen
Firechip. Sowas wie Firebase, nur nicht Firebase. Ja, dann ist es sowas, okay. Warum schreiben die
nicht einfach irgendeinen Satz, den Leute verstehen, die das Projekt noch nicht im Detail kennen? Ich
weiß nicht, das kriegen viele Projekte irgendwie nicht richtig hin. Open Source Notification
Infrastructure. Ja, wahrscheinlich außer für iOS. AI? Moment, sowas ist erlaubt? Ein Windows
und Office Aktivator? Das heißt, man braucht keine Lizenz-Keys mehr? Beziehungsweise Lizenz-Keys
gibt es ja in der Form meistens schon gar nicht mehr. Java-Trended? Ah, nein. Algorithms. Ich
kann das nicht aussprechen. Algorithm implemented in Java. Programming Books, Code Camp, Tooljet,
Low-Code-Plattform. Okay, geh mal weg. Open-Core-Legacy-Patcher. Ach, das ist irgendein
macOS-Ding. Ich juck's. Docs. Magic Mirror. Dass das immer noch trendet, das ist eines der
most useless, overratesten Smart Home Dinger überhaupt. AI? AI? AI? Ne. Blazingly fast,
written in Rust. Wir haben ja gestern wieder festgestellt, als wir den Valor Mart gemacht
haben, es sollten mehr Leute Rust lernen, weil Blazingly fast Orca-Slicer. Ah, okay,
ein Steuerungs-Code-Generator für 3D-Drucker. Vielleicht taugt der. China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Bruno am Start. Ja, sieht aus wie Postman. Aber es ist nicht Postman. Es ist Bruno. Was
ist rausgekommen am Valor Mart? Ich glaub, wir haben sogar noch das Ergebnis. Ne. Haben wir nicht?
Ich weiß nicht. Es kam raus, ich soll FDP wählen. Der Markt regelt das. Moin, hat jemand Erfahrung
zu DDR5-RAM-128-Gig 4x32G-Sticks vs. 64? Du meinst, ob das geht? Ja, 128 sind auf jeden Fall
überdimensioniert. Ja, wenn du einen Anwendungszweck führst, warum nicht? Okay, keine Ahnung.
Sind 128 Gig in 2 Sticks nicht unverhältnismäßig teurer als in 4 Sticks? Es ist jetzt nicht so,
als würde die Taktrate unglaublich viel ausmachen. Ich weiß gar nicht, mit was es meinen RAM getakt
hat. Sieht man das im Task-Manager? Scheinbar nicht, oder? Doch, hier, guck mal. Alter,
der Task-Manager, hier, IQ-Shit. Das hätte ich jetzt aber nicht gedacht. Ja, wenn es die nicht
in 2 Sticks gibt, dann kannst du auch nicht in 2 Sticks das machen, oder? Boah, ich bin übelst
im Arsch. Okay. Also, ich habe 2x32 Gig drinnen und ihr seht es bei der RAM-Auslastung. Es ist
jetzt nicht so, als würde ich hier in irgendeiner Art und Weise da an mein Limit kommen. Selbst wenn
ich hingehe... Ach, jetzt weiß ich wieder, was ich vorhin sagen wollte. Ist mir gerade random
wieder eingefallen. Ich habe euren Tipp mal befolgt. Wir wollten auch gestern die Strecke
angucken, wo ich Fahrrad in den Berg hochgefahren bin. Euren Tipp befolgt und habe mal in Apple Maps
geguckt, ob die Apple Maps Lookaround oder wie die das nennen haben. Und ja, die haben den
kompletten Weg Streetview-mäßig in Apple Maps drinnen. Leider hat Google den nicht und wie
hieß das andere? Mapillary hat das auch nicht. Aber Apple hat es drinnen. Leider kann man Apple
Maps nur auf Apple-Geräten verwenden und nicht im Browser. Deswegen bringt mir das jetzt hier auch
nichts. Es sei denn, wir installieren uns macOS in der 4M und benutzen es dann in der 4M. Man muss
aber halt sagen, macOS in der 4M läuft halt mega kacke in der 4M. Aber um mal irgendwie was aufzumachen
und kurz zu zeigen, reicht es natürlich. Ich mache mal kurz Arch, by the way. Wir sind ja hier
Rolling Release. Machen mal eine Runde Package Updates. Packt mein Bestes. Guck mal, wie schnell das geht.
Yam und Updaten jetzt erstmal drei Stunden rumgerödelt. Vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben.
Zwei, drei Minuten rumgerödelt, bis das durch gewesen wäre. Und Packt man macht einfach flutsch,
bam, fertig. Bei meinem Rechner vielleicht nur, ja, aber trotzdem. Ich habe es ja schon mal
ausprobiert, virtualisiert. Allerdings war das macOS in Virtualbox. Da gab es irgendein Installer-Skript
auf GitHub für. Und das ging, aber das war nicht schön. Okay, erstmal Updaten und dann Reboot. Und
hoffen, dass der Kernel, wenn ich jetzt den neuen Kernel nehme, die 4M nicht laggt. Es gibt nämlich
anscheinend irgendein Problem mit aktuellen Linux Kernels und meinem 4M Setup, dass der Input laggt.
Und um das zu beheben, habe ich den aktuellen LTS Kernel laufen geguckt. 6.5.5, wobei, ist das der LTS
Kernel? Werden wir gleich sehen. Wo am besten eine eigene Maildomain hosten? Will das endlich
angehen? Ich würde überhaupt nicht E-Mail selbst hosten. Also ich meine eigene Domain hosten, da
gibt es, also eigene Domain registrieren, gar kein Ding. Habe ich auch einige. Aber da E-Mail selbst
machen, eigentlich macht das überhaupt keinen Sinn. Wenn du einfach nur E-Mails bekommen willst auf der
Domain, dann bietet es so gut wie jeder Registrar so eine Catch-All-Weiterleitung. Und wenn dir das
nicht reicht, dann würde ich irgendeinen Anbieter nehmen, der das macht. Keine Ahnung, ich würde es
echt nicht selbst machen. E-Mail selbst hosten ist so ein Ding, das habe ich lange aufgegeben. So,
mal gucken, ob der Lag weg ist. Ich habe jetzt nicht auf die 4M geguckt. Ich könnte das schon
direkt gesehen. So, schauen wir mal, ob der Lag weg ist. Ganz einfach testen, indem ich die Taste
durchgedrückt habe. Und wenn es laggt. Leute, scheint nicht mehr zu laggen, oder? Fixed, würde
ich mal sagen. Lag fixed. Ja, daheim mit dynamischer IP hosten geht eh nicht. Nimmt keiner deine E-Mails
an. Dachte ehrlich gesagt, es ging hauptsächlich ums Empfangen. Wobei selbst da, wenn du willst,
dass es direkt eingeliefert wird, kannst du auch vergessen. So, ich würde sagen, Lag ist weg.
Tackle. Oh, nice. Dann gucken wir nochmal schnell fertig. Okay, das ist das, was ich trenne. Was
trenne denn im .NET Umfeld? Langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig, langweilig,
Maui, MonkaS. Wie gesagt, ich warte nur noch auf den Blogpost von Microsoft, dass Maui eingestellt
wird. Langweilig. Got Potato. Okay, was ist das? No description. Based on the history of
potato. Ah, Security, stellts. Okay. Hätte ich vom Namen her mir eigentlich schon denken können.
Osu! Endlich, ja. Endlich trenne das mal. So, Terraria Mods. Demo Anwendung. Langweilig,
langweilig, langweilig, langweilig. Was? Noch mehr Security, stellts. Langweilig. Was ist das für
ein bescheuertes, bescheuerte Projekt Description? Da weiß man schon mal nicht, was es sein soll.
Ach, okay, doch. Kerberos. Das ergibt tatsächlich sogar Sinn, dass es so heißt. Okay,
alles nicht so spannend. Naja, war jetzt nicht so viel Spannendes drin in dieser Woche. Ja,
also nicht auf das Video von Leeroy. Ich habe auf das Reaction Video, auf das Leeroy Video
reaktet. Das reicht, das reicht. Auf das Original Video müssen wir nicht nochmal reacten. Live
underfloor, richtig. Ja, müssen wir nicht nochmal reacten. Juck die Nase. Genug Reakception. Wie
lange das her ist? Ich glaube letzte Woche. Du kannst so viel reacten auf Reaction von mir,
wo ich reacte, wie du willst. Ich glaube letzte Woche haben wir das angeguckt, oder? Wo blorts?
Es ist auch hier. Aufwachen schreien. Jetzt siehst du es sogar schon in der Vorschau. Es ist
auch sogar schon in der Vorschau drin. Netflix Games sind schlecht. Ich wusste noch nicht mal,
dass Netflix überhaupt Games hat. Seit wann hat Netflix Games? Nicht Gains, Games. So,
hat YouTube noch irgendwas Spannendes? Hitler uses Docker. Das ist halt so ein bisschen
wahrscheinlich wie für einen Spanier die El Resitas Videos. Die Dinger sind halt meistens
nicht lustig, weil du halt die Sprache verstehst, die da drin gesprochen wird. Und die Amis oder
generell die restliche Welt kickdoubletoots sich ein auf die Videos. Ich glaube ein Spanier,
ein Spanier findet die ganzen kickdoubletoots El Resitas Videos nicht lustig, weil er halt
Spanisch versteht. Nach 20 Jahren PC, warum ich zum Mac gewechselt bin? Also ein bisschen
Hipster geht immer. Mal ganz davon abgesehen, wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, wenn ich mich,
also wenn ich nichts hätte unter Windows, was halt besonders gut unter Windows funktioniert
und nicht unter Mac oder schwierig unter Linux, das ist ja der Grund, warum ich Windows verwende,
dann würde ich auch lieber Mac verwenden oder gleich Linux. Aber es gibt halt Dinger,
die ich unter Windows mache, die sich anbieten unter Windows zu machen. Zum Beispiel Spiele
spielen oder meine Videos für YouTube oder auch Livestream, wobei man das auch in anderen
Plattformen kann. Deswegen bin ich halt unter Windows und unter Linux. Parallel. Also Linux
ist schon mal allein schon deswegen wichtig, dass wir das hier anmachen können. Counter Strike 2
killt CSGO. Ja, da ist ja von auszugehen, dass CSGO ziemlich deadge ist, wenn CS2 richtig raus ist.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher. Ist CS2 richtig schon am Start oder ist das immer noch so Public
Beta jetzt? Es gibt kein CSGO mehr. Siehst du mal, inwieweit ich das nicht verfolgt habe. Ja,
ja wird überschrieben. Ja, ergibt ja auch irgendwo Sinn. Die wollen ja nicht zwei Main
CS Titel so parallel haben als Service Game. Kann man. Verstehe ich schon. Ist es wieder nicht,
was es hier gibt. So, was können wir uns dann angucken? Was haben wir denn hier? Windows?
Was ist das denn? Windows 11 Update, was ihr euch schon immer gewünscht habt. Okay, das ist das.
Das ist wobei es eigentlich. Wir gucken das, aber eigentlich müssen wir es nicht gucken,
weil wir haben es letztens in der VM ausprobiert. Das einzige Gute an diesem Windows 11 Update,
was mich persönlich richtig überzeugt hat und was absolut lächerlich ist, dass es nicht,
dass es nicht drin ist, also dass es bisher nicht drin war. Was bin ich hier sehend? Und
dass man hier die Sachen entgruppieren kann. Der Rest war jetzt eher Verhalten. Ja,
Moment, LSD Reaction. Moment, was zum Wort? Das verstehe ich. Wir gucken jetzt. Wir gucken. Also
ich werde mir das nicht angucken, weil ich habe keinen Bock auf Reaktion Videos zu reacten. Das
ist immer absolut Pega Kram. Ach, LSD steht für lohnt sich das? Ach so, ja, dann lohnt sich das.
Ja, Deutschland neue Megaprojekte. Wenn wir Megaprojekte machen, dann werden die ja prinzipiell
immer nicht fertig oder oder irgendwann 30 Jahre zu spät. So, was kann man uns dann angucken? Was
haben wir hier? Wir gucken das jetzt schnell an. Zwölf Minuten fertig aus. Hast du schon
ausprobiert? Ich habe mir das angeguckt und nicht den großen Vorteil davon erkannt, zumal ich
komplett mein Entwicklungsgram unter Windows eingestellt habe. Ich verwende exklusiv nur
noch meine Linux dafür. Und ja, und ich war schon seit Jahren dort nur unter Linux. Ich weiß ja
immer noch nicht, warum manche Leute der Meinung sind, das wird nicht gescheit funktionieren.
Spätestens seit es Raider gibt und .NET Core funktioniert das besser unter Linux als unter
Windows. Für mich zumindest. So, dann lasst uns hier mal kurz reinschauen. Guck mal hier. Guck
mal hier, das ist Windows 11 und das bekommt jetzt ein großes Update und hat dann hier unten so ein
Copilot-Icon. Ja und noch viel besser. Es hat endlich entkopierbare Taskleisten-Dinger. Der
größte Abfuck seit Windows 11 Release. Man kann es endlich entkopieren. Ich meine, die Taskleiste
hat immer noch weniger Funktionalität als unter Windows 98, aber immerhin, immerhin sind absolute
Basics wieder da. Ist das ein Windows-integrierte künstliche Intelligenz-Tool von Microsoft? Das
haben wir sogar schon ausprobiert im Stream. Das war okay, aber ich verstehe immer noch nicht genau
den großen, ja weiß ich nicht, den ganz großen Sinn davon. Du kannst diesem KI-Tool sagen, Windows
Dark Theme, Windows Light Theme und sowas, was für die Settings ganz cool ist, weil niemand mehr
durchblickt, in welchem Settings-Dialog unter Windows irgendwas zu finden ist. Für den Rest muss es
eigentlich nicht wirklich im Desktop integriert sein. Ich möchte eine Eingabe-Aufforderung haben,
aber mit gelber Schrift auf rotem Hintergrund. Zack. Oder ich brauche ganz dringend ein neues
Hintergrundbild mit einer Seekuh, die mit einem Jetpack über Hannover fliegt. Zack. Also ein
bisschen Handarbeit muss ich noch übernehmen, aber Copilot sagt mir zumindest genau, was zu
tun ist. Und es gibt KI jetzt auch in anderen Windows-eigenen Tools. Zum Beispiel hier im
Screenshot-Programm. Das ist auch schon lustige Entwicklung, oder? Die Lösung ist natürlich nicht,
die Settings einfacher zu machen, sondern eine KI zu entwickeln, die einem hilft,
dadurch zu navigieren. Ja, so sieht es halt aus 2023. Snipping-Tool. Ich sehe hier ein Bild mit
einem Text und habe keine Lust, den abzuschreiben. Rahmen drüber ziehen, dann wird der Text erkannt,
ist im Zwischenspeicher und ich kann den dann irgendwo reinwerfen. Ganz cool, oder? Moment,
das heißt auch Captures. Na gut, das sind die ganz, ganz alten Captures. Die funktionieren ja
schon seit irgendwie fünf Jahren nicht mehr richtig. Dann wird der Text erkannt, ist im
Zwischenspeicher und ich kann den dann irgendwo reinwerfen. Ganz cool, oder? Und man kann endlich
die blöde Taskleisten-Gruppierung abschreiben. Ja, endlich! Das ist ohne Scheiß das einzig
Sinnvolle für mich in diesem Update, dass man dieses nervige Gruppiertsein von den ganzen...
Ich meine, man sieht es doch hier an meiner Taskleiste. Guck mal, ich habe so viel Platz
und dieser Platz wird nie für irgendwas benutzt. Nie. Der ist einfach immer leer.
Wahnsinn. Ich zeige euch in diesem Video, wie ihr das jetzt schon nutzen könnt. Vieles klappt
allerdings auch noch nicht so gut. Bleibt dran. Moment. Wait a minute. Ich dachte,
das ist jetzt raus. Soll das nicht 22H2 werden? Ist nicht bald Windows 23, sorry. 23H2. Ist das
jetzt nicht langsam? Aber sicher mal so. Ach, im vierten Quartal kommt das erst. Wobei wir haben
das vierte Quartal. Haben wir das vierte? Ja, wir haben das vierte Quartal. Quartal ist drei
Monate. Release Date. Ja, das haben wir ja schon ausprobiert. Dieses Video wird gesponsert von
Poggers. Sehr laut. Moment. Ich kriege so lange technische Beratung, wie der Hersteller Bock
drauf hat und solange es den Hersteller noch gibt. Wobei eins muss ich echt mal sagen. Ich bin mir
nicht mehr sicher, was es für einen Hersteller genau war. Ich glaube Corsair war das. Oder
Corsair oder wie auch immer man die ausspricht. Richtig. Von denen habe ich mal auf Ebay. Also
ich habe mir mal auf Ebay so einen. Das war zu der Zeit recht modern. Es gab so Mini. Die Dinger
gibt es heute gar nicht mehr. So was in der Richtung habe ich mir damals gekauft. Das ist
schon ganz lange her. Es war wahrscheinlich irgendwie so 2003 oder so. Keine Ahnung. Es ist
lange her. Zumindest war dort Corsair RAM drin. Arbeitsspeicher. Wahrscheinlich war es eher 2007
oder so denke ich mal. Zumindest war da Corsair RAM drin und der war auch schon ein paar Jahre
alt. Das war gebraucht, was ich mir gekauft habe. Der eine RAM Riegel hatte Probleme und da habe
ich mit der Seriennummer geguckt, was das für ein RAM ist und war nachher gestellt worden. Der RAM
war irgendwie acht Jahre oder so. Sieben, acht Jahre alt. Aber das war Premium Corsair RAM und
da haben sie geworben mit lebenslanger Garantie. Und da habe ich den Support angeschrieben. Damals
acht Jahre oder so. Sieben Jahre, nachdem der RAM verkauft wurde. Da habe ich gesagt,
Jungs mein RAM ist kaputt. Lebenslange Garantie. Die haben mir anstandslos ein neues Pack geschickt.
Also da fand ich schon etwas verkehrt. ... Anlagen ist 2024 ready. Da gilt ja die neue
Bagatelle Grenze und die dritte Generation erzeugt auch bis zu 30 Prozent mehr Leistung
dank intelligenten Wechselrichter und bifazialen Solarmodulen. Und die Wechselrichter kommen aus
Deutschland. Schaut doch mal auf privat.de slash Stecker minus Solaranlagen. Erbung Ende. Ja Mensch,
endlich mal wieder ein Windows Video. Hatten wir schon lange nicht mehr. Aber Windows kriegt jetzt
wirklich einen ganzen Haufen neuer Funktionen und das ist ein Video wert. 23H2 heißt das Update,
was in den nächsten Tagen ausgespielt werden soll. Vielleicht habt ihr das auch schon. Details dazu,
was, wann, wie kommt und wie ihr... Ich habe das Gefühl, ein Ausbilder erzählt irgendwelche
merkwürdigen Sachen und weiß nicht, wovon er spricht. Also ganz ehrlich, eine Software,
die jeder haben will. Du musst erst mal eine Software herstellen, die jeder haben will.
Das heißt, du musst einfach was finden, was jeder haben will. So easy ist das nicht. Und
die muss zumindest auch mal halbwegs das halten, was sie verspricht, weil ansonsten kauft sich
dafür garantiert keiner Support. Also insofern, wo das gut funktioniert ist, wenn du SAP bist oder
sowas, was schon ein größeres Business Enterprise Modell hat und eben schon verbreitet ist oder
Oracle. Ja, Oracle ist noch geileres Beispiel für so nach dem Motto, ja eigentlich brauchen wir keine
Oracle-Datenbank, aber wir machen trotzdem eine Oracle-Datenbank. Dann schon, aber so,
du als einzelner Entwickler kannst du das eigentlich mehr oder weniger knicken.
Ihr beschleunigen könnt, dass ihr die neuen Funktionen bekommt, gibt es am Ende des Videos.
So, jetzt aber erst mal die unserer Meinung nach fünf wichtigsten Funktionen des 23H2
Windows Updates. Nummer 1, Taskbar-Gruppierung ist endlich abschaltbar. Ja, beste. Ja, das klingt nach
keinen Änderung, aber laut eurer Kommentare in älteren Windows 11 3.0-Gruppen sieht euch endlich
keiner an. Und ich habe mich da ja auch schon mehrfach drüber aufgeregt. Bislang war es so,
wenn ihr zwei Fenster eines Programms geöffnet habt, dann hat Windows die gruppiert. Es ist so
dumm. Das ist dann im schlimmsten Fall so. Es ist so dumm, ich verstehe bis heute nicht den Sinn
dahinter, warum man das haben will. Man hat ein 16 zu 9, teilweise einen super ultra-Widescreen-Monitor,
aber nein, von der Taskleiste benutzt man nur das erste Viertel.
Die auch noch gleich heißen. Ihr geht da also mit der Maus drüber und da steht dann zweimal
einfach das Gleiche. Es wird nicht mal eine Vorschau angezeigt, die kommt nur bei ungruppierten
Programmen. Also absolut nachvollziehbar, dass das viele Leute nervig finden, weil man im Zweifel
ausprobieren muss, welches Fenster richtig ist. Richtig dumm. So, nun kann man aber auf die Taskleiste
rechts klicken, dann Taskleiste-Einstellungen auswählen, Verhalten der Taskleiste und auf
Taskleisten-Schaltflächen kombinieren und Beschriftungen ausblenden und von immer auf
nie gehen. Ja, dann werden die nicht mehr gruppiert. Endlich! Aber zumindest bei meiner
Version gibt es hier trotzdem keine Vorschauen, wenn ein Programm mehrere Fenster... Ich finde
es auch sehr befremdlich, dass du eins anklickst und kriegst mehrere angezeigt. Das ist sehr
weird-champig. Ganz ehrlich, ich verstehe nicht, wie man es schaffen kann. 2023, also nach 40 Jahren
Windows oder so, das schlechter zu machen als unter Windows 98. Das leuchtet mir nicht ein.
Und ich dann da mit der Maus drüber gehe. Du kannst ja noch nicht mal mehr gescheit Dinge
auf die Taskleiste ziehen. Gehen nur ganz bestimmte Sachen. Statt einem Vorschau-Bild
kommt ja dann wieder nur die Liste der Fenster. Ich hoffe, dass das ein Bug ist,
der noch behoben wird. Microsoft gibt einfach einen Scheiß drauf mittlerweile. Ja, das habe
ich echt nicht gebraucht. Ich gehe auch ganz stark davon aus, dass ich das so gut wie nie benutze.
Wobei, man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht. Vielleicht stellt sich das ja doch ganz cool
raus für manche Sachen. Aber wahrscheinlich werde ich das so gut wie nie benutzen.
Ja, rechts neben dem Start-Button und dem Suchfenster befindet sich nun dieses Symbol
hier. Das ist der sogenannte... Also Chat, ich weiß, dass das wahrscheinlich sogar so ist.
Ja, wahrscheinlich hat sich das wirklich einer gedacht, dass es was mit Aesthetics zu tun hat.
Ernsthaft, wenn Microsoft wirklich denkt, bei Windows wäre Aesthetisch noch irgendwas zu
machen, der benutzt sein eigenes OS nicht. Windows ist so ein zusammengestückeltes
Mischmasch der letzten 30 Jahre. Mein Lieblingsmenü, um das zu demonstrieren,
ist immer noch das. Ich meine, das hier kennt ihr ja alle noch. Aber mein Lieblingsmenü,
um das zu demonstrieren, ist immer noch das hier. Einmal, einmal das hier, ja. So,
das hier und Properties und dann Customize das hier. Guckt euch mal... Also erstens,
dass man das hier schon mal nicht resizen kann. Guckt euch mal die Icons an, die hier drin sind.
Leute, das sind einfach die hässlichsten Oldschool-Icons überhaupt. Warum hat Windows
nicht mal eine gescheite Icon-Datenbank drin, bzw. einen ordentlichen Icon-Customize-Dialog?
Ihr wolltet schon immer mal diesen 8-Bit-Pixel-Baum haben als Icon, oder? Das sind nicht mal 256
Farben, das sind 16 Farben oder so. Also ich glaube, dieser... Guckt euch das hier an,
Mann! Das ist WordPad von Windows 3.11. Da hieß es noch nicht... Wie hieß denn das?
Right hieß das, glaube ich, damals. Hier, guckt mal. Dieser Dialog ist das beste Beispiel dafür.
Das ist Windows-Design-Mischmasch der letzten 40 Jahre. Hier, beste hier. High-Res. High-Res
Bookmark-Pictures. Also da ist bei Windows wirklich nichts mehr zu retten. Copilot,
eine auf Bing-Chat basierende KI. Und Bing-Chat basiert ja wiederum auf GPT-4 von OpenAI,
also den Machern von Chat-GPT. Und die beiden Tools sind ähnlich. Also Chat-GPT und Bing-Chat
haben aber unterschiedliche Charaktere. Darüber hatten wir ja schon mal ein Video gemacht. Bing
neigt zu beleidigten Verhalten, wenn ich das mal so vermenschlichen darf. Also wenn Bing irgendwas
nicht passt, beendet es sehr abrupt das Gespräch. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das Bing macht,
dass es nicht so leicht entklar ist. Microsoft hat mit selbstlernender AI, die ein bisschen in
die falsche Richtung läuft, haben sie ja schon Erfahrungen gemacht. Erinnert sich noch einer an
den Nazi-Twitter-Bot von Microsoft? Die haben vor Jahren mal... Tay oder so hieß dieses Ding. Die
haben vor Jahren mal einen Twitter-Bot rausgebracht, der eben menschlich antworten
sollte und lernt, was so abgeht. Problem ist halt Twitter. Und der hat halt gelernt, was auf Twitter
so abgeht. Und der hat dann schon nach ein paar Tagen übelsten, fragwürdigen Kram gepostet. Und
da wurde dann auch abgeschaltet direkt. Kann es sein, dass du ein bisschen dumm bist? Ist
auch fies, ja. Aber dann sagt Co-Pilot, das ist nicht nett von dir, auf Wiedersehen. Und dann
wird mir hier im Co-Pilot vorgeschlagen, dass ich mich entschuldigen kann. Aber das wird alles dann
nicht mehr registriert, wenn ich da drauf klicke. Ich muss dann die Konversation ganz neu beginnen,
also auf fangen wir von vorne an klicken. Aber gut, so ist er halt drauf, der oder die Bing Co-Pilot.
Wenn ihr jetzt übrigens denkt, hä, ich kann Bing Chat ja auch einfach im Browser benutzen. Ist dieser
Co-Pilot einfach nur ein Shortcut da drauf? Jein. Also die Funktionalität ist auf den ersten Blick
gleich. Das heißt, wenn ich sage, schreibt mir ein Gedicht über Seekühe, dann kommt bei Bing Chat
im Browser und bei Co-Pilot das gleiche raus. Aber der Co-Pilot kann einige Windows-Funktionen
direkt aufrufen. Also zum Beispiel in den Dunkelmodus schalten, Fokus-Sitzungen aktivieren
oder vorinstallierte Programme wie den Editor starten. Soll ich euch mal was verraten? Wisst ihr,
was so richtig cool wäre? Wenn man unter Windows für solche Funktionen einfach sinnvolle Shortcuts
festlegen könnte. Zum Beispiel, wie ich es hier mit Desktop-Switchen habe, dass man das einfach
auf einen Shortcut legen kann. Ich meine, ich kann unter Windows auch Desktop-Switchen, aber
nur relativ umständlich im Vergleich zu Windows-Taste 1, 2 hier. Oder dass ich einfach mir
auf Shortcuts legen kann, was ich auf Shortcuts legen will und dann ist gut. Das wäre natürlich
nice, aber das ist zu PC-zentrierte Bedienung. Microsoft will ja lieber Tablet-zentrierte
Bedienung auf dem Desktop machen. Sieht man ja auch den ganzen Anwendungen an. Guckt euch
aktuelle Windows-Software an. Die sieht nicht aus wie für den Desktop. Die sieht aus wie irgendeine
beschnittenes Tablet-Version davon. Immer noch eine Sicherheitfrage abnicken. Programme starten.
Geht also definitiv smoother, wenn man einfach auf Start drückt und dann EDI eingibt und Return drückt.
Das ist ja nice. Als ich Bing gefragt habe, wie ich erkenne, ob mein Fensterrahmen aus PVC ist,
hat es gesagt, ich soll mein Fensterrahmen anzünden und schauen, ob es tropft. Wahrscheinlich hätte
das funktioniert. Ich weiß gar nicht, warum du dich darüber aufregst. Doch, legit? Nee. Virtuelle
Desktops sind immer die gleichen. Das Einzige, was an Desktops virtuell ist, sind nicht die
Desktops, sondern die Fenster. Das heißt, es virtuelle Desktops zu nennen unter Windows ist
halt richtig bescheuert. Ja, Teams 2.0. Gibt es das nicht seit gestern oder vorgestern? Das ist
auch der Grund, warum das alte Teams jetzt Teams Classic heißt. Bei uns auf der Arbeit wurde Teams
letztens umbenannt von Teams in Teams Classic. Was da neu ist, ich weiß es nicht. Ich habe mich
damit noch nicht beschäftigt. Das gucken wir uns tatsächlich mal an. What's new Teams 2.0
Preview. Es ist nicht mehr elektronen-based, oder? Dann wird halt der Editor gestartet. Aber wenn man
zum Beispiel nicht so genau weiß, wo man in den Windows-Menüs den Dunkelmodus aktiviert, dafür
ist der Copilot dann natürlich praktisch. Was mich einigermaßen beeindruckt hat, ich habe Copilot
gesagt, ich möchte gerne eine Eingabeaufforderung mit gelber Schrift auf rotem Grund haben. Und
Copilot hat dann gefragt, soll ich eine Eingabeaufforderung öffnen? Ja, sollst du. Aber
das war dann halt mein normales Terminal ohne die geänderten Farben. Ich habe dann noch mal
nachgefragt und dann spuckte Copilot aus, ich soll doch einfach mal Color CE eingeben. Ja, und das
hat dann sofort geklappt. Das ist also alles so eine Mischung aus Automatismen und manuellen
Eingriffen. Aber man kommt schon irgendwie zum Ziel und das in einigen Fällen womöglich schneller
als mit einer normalen Suchmaschine. Copilot beziehungsweise Bing Chat haben jetzt als
Bildgenerator DOLL-I3 integriert. Das Ding ist noch nicht so gut wie Midjourney, aber halt dafür
kostenlos und es kann zumindest mit Text besser umgehen als mit Midjourney. Hier steht zum Beispiel
CT 3003, das kann man sogar lesen. Bei Midjourney kommen meist nur irgendwelche
Hieroglyphen. Ja, und dann kann man halt einfach sagen, ich möchte mein Windows hinter... Ja, das
ist mir auch schon aufgefallen, dass AI in Bildgenerierung sehr viele Probleme hat mit
Text. Deswegen ist es damit auch schwierig, irgendwelche Produktlogos, wo Text drinne
vorkommt, zu designen. Einfach Logos geht, aber mit Text ist schwierig. Eins mit einer
Seekuh austauschen, die auf einem Jetpack über Hannover fliegt. Und dann öffnet der Copilot den
Hintergrundbild-Dialog und generiert das Bild. Ich muss das Bild dann manuell abspeichern,
aber kann dann hier direkt auf Fotos durchsuchen klicken und zack, habe ich das Hintergrundbild.
Und das Bild selbst finde ich ganz okay, muss ich sagen, auch wenn hier Hannover einfach aus
ganz vielen Versionen des neuen Rathauses besteht. Manchmal geht es auch ein bisschen
in die Hose, als ich gesagt habe, dass Copilot so ein Fenster einrasten soll, hat es das zwar
gemacht, aber wenn ich dann hier auf Erkunden geklickt habe, kamen dann Infos über Lichtöffnungen
im Bauwesen. Wikipedia zu Fenster. Ja, also Fenster. Aber der Copilot ist ja auch noch ganz klar als
Vorschau-Version deklariert, sogar hier im Icon ist unten Pre zu lesen für Preview. Da
wird also noch dran rumoptimiert. Ich gehe davon aus, dass in Zukunft mehr praktische Sachen möglich
sein werden. Sehr interessant wird vor allem auch der angekündigte kostenpflichtige Copilot
für Office 365, wo man dann direkt in Excel und Word und so weiter Dinge generieren lassen kann.
Das dauert aber noch ein bisschen. Nummer drei, Texterkennung im Screenshot-Tool. Diese Funktion
finde ich wirklich praktisch. Man ruft einfach mit Windows-Taste Shift-S, das in Windows integrierte
Screenshot-Programm Snipping-Tool auf, markiert in einem Bild irgendeinen Text und klickt dann hier
unten auf dieses Text-Aktionen-Symbol hier und dann wird der Text erkannt. Das ist in der Tat
ganz praktisch. Kann es auch QR-Codes lesen, das wäre natürlich auch noch mal extra nice.
Also zumindest ich kann das sehr gut gebrauchen, weil ich oft den Fall habe, dass ich zum Beispiel
Text googeln oder bingen will, der aber nur als Bild vorliegt. Also ich duck da go immer nur.
Wenn mir irgendjemand irgendeine Info als Bild schickt und ich die dann nicht. Haben andere schon
lange. Microsoft braucht ja da immer eine Weile für. Ich mein, guckt euch mal Notepad an und
jeden x-beliebigen anderen Text-Editor. Bei Microsoft dauert das alles. Manuell abschreiben
muss. Das klappt übrigens sogar mit alten einfachen Captures. Nummer 4. Wirklich gute
Live-Untertitel. Das gibt es schon etwas länger. Das ist jetzt nicht erst im 23H2-Update dazu
gekommen, aber weil die Funktion viele noch nicht kennen, erwähne ich die hier noch mal. Windows
kann jetzt Live-Untertitel auf Deutsch und zwar funktioniert das mit jeder Audioquelle. Zum
Beispiel bei Podcast hier mit CT-Ablenk. Die Windows-Untertitel sind qualitativ deutlich
besser als zum Beispiel die automatischen von YouTube und die können auch sogar Groß- und
Kleinschreibung und Satz zeigen. Geh mal davon aus, dass Whisper dahinter steckt. Das ist ja
Open Source von OpenAI und OpenAI arbeitet ja mit Microsoft zusammen, wird wohl Whisper sein. Zum
Aktivieren dieser Live-Untertitel einfach auf Start und dann Live-Eingebener werden die dann
schon vorgeschlagen. Für Deutsch muss man dann eventuell noch einen Sprachpakt nachinstallieren,
weil die Erkennung lokal auf dem eigenen Rechner und nicht in der Cloud funktioniert.
Hallo, ich wollte euch noch einmal kurz fragen, ob ihr vielleicht Lust habt, einmal unten hier
auf Abonnieren zu klicken und vielleicht auch die Glocke, weil wir sind kurz vor 100.000 und
dann kriegen wir so einen geilen, so eine YouTube, so eine Plakette, die wir uns an die Wand hängen.
Der silberne Playbutton. Ich überlege gerade, wo habe ich denn meinen silbernen Playbutton?
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage. Irgendwo im Schrank wahrscheinlich. Ich habe den hier nicht an der
Wand hängen oder so. Ich habe keine Ahnung, wo ich den habe. Wirklich, wir sind da wirklich sehr
heiß drauf. Wir sind peinliche Menschen. Aber wenn ihr uns den Gefallen tun wollt,
dann klickt da doch gerne mal. Dankeschön. Nummer 5. Ganz viel Kleinkram. Windows 23
H2 hat über 100 neue Funktionen. Unter anderem hat der Explorer jetzt hier oben so einen empfohlen
Balken, wo Windows die für mich vermutlich relevantesten Dateien anzeigt. Naja, das klappt
bei mir nur so halb gut, würde ich sagen. Ja, und jetzt noch ein paar Sachen, die ich hier jetzt
erwähne. Die sind bei mir aber noch nicht freigeschaltet. Deshalb konnte ich die noch
nicht ausprobieren. Aber Microsoft hat sie angekündigt. Es soll eine automatische Backup
Funktion. Das haben wir doch ausprobiert. Das war doch ganz grausam weird champig. Das war das,
wo ich nicht gecheckt habe, wie man restoren kann. Könnt ihr euch daran erinnern? Backup ging,
aber restore ging nicht. Sehr, sehr merkwürdig. Da hat die Welt drauf gewartet. Paint endlich
KI Support. Das funktioniert auch. Das haben wir ausprobiert. Allerdings, wohlgemerkt,
nur entpacken, nicht packen. Müsst ihr also in Zukunft nicht mehr den Shareware Hinweis von
WinRar wegklicken. Ja, und jetzt noch mal ganz kurz die Hintergründe des Updates. 23 H2 heißt
das. Hatte ich ja schon gesagt. Und das klingt irgendwie, als wäre es das zweite Update im Jahr
2023. Aber so funktioniert das nicht bei Microsoft. Das ist einfach nur der Releasezeitpunkt. Zweites
Halbjahr. Ursprünglich war das mal ein bisschen wie bei Ubuntu. Bei Ubuntu hieß es ja auch 2204,
22.10. Das hatte Microsoft auch. Dann haben sie H1, H2 draus gemacht. Aber es muss nicht zwangsläufig
unbedingt H1 gegeben haben. Microsoft, warum auch immer. Es gibt laut Microsoft zurzeit immer nur
ein großes Funktions Update pro Jahr. Das hieß letztes Jahr 22 H2 und dieses Jahr 23 H2. H1
Version gab es nicht. Also zumindest nicht in der Windows Desktop Version, sondern nur für Microsoft
Holographic, für die AR Brille HoloLens. Moment, das Ding benutzt doch irgendjemand. Sehr speziell.
Okay, jetzt habe ich euch wahrscheinlich verwirrt. Sorry. Wichtig ist nur, das große jährliche
Funktions Update kommt sehr wahrscheinlich für alle Windows Installationen in den nächsten
Tagen über Windows Update. Womöglich ist das Update bei euch sogar schon installiert,
aber Microsoft schaltet die Funktion erst nach. Was ist eigentlich aus Google Class geworden?
Gibt es das noch? Das Einzige, was ich von Google Class in Erinnerung hatte, ist,
dass einer der Google Gründer was mit der Google Class Entwicklerin hatte. Fragt mich nicht,
warum das in den Medien gewesen ist damals. Aber ich glaube, das gibt es nicht mehr. Nach
frei. Es ist leider sehr, sehr undurchsichtig und ich vermute, dass sogar Microsoft nicht so genau
weiß, wann, was, wo kommt. Fakt ist, zumindest den Copilot bekommt ihr in der EU erstmal nicht
automatisch, obwohl der sogar in anderen Ländern schon in der 22 H2 aktiv ist. Laut der Website
Dr. Windows ist der Grund dafür, dass der Copilot offenbar zur Zeit nicht im Einklang mit dem Digital
Markets Act der EU ist. Wenn ihr das KI Tool trotzdem schon nutzen wollt, klickt ihr einfach
mit rechts auf den Desktop, dann Neu, dann Verknüpfung. Dann fügt ihr diesen Befehl hier ein,
steht unten auch in der Beschreibung und nennt die Verknüpfung dann zum Beispiel Copilot. Wenn
ihr die Verknüpfung dann doppelt klickt, startet der Copilot. Tada. Und wenn ihr auch die anderen
Sachen alle ganz dringend sofort haben wollt und ein bisschen risikofreudig seid, könnt ihr unter
Einstellung Windows Update hier das Windows Insider Programm aktivieren. Das mache ich nur in der
4M. Das gebe ich mir für meinen normalen Rechner nicht. In absteigender Stabilität. Canary Channel,
da werden auch Sachen getestet, die am Ende womöglich gar nicht in der finalen Windows
Version kommen. Der Entwicklungskanal ist etwas stabiler, kann aber auch noch ziemlich buggy sein.
Der Beta Kanal ist schon zuverlässiger und der Release Preview Kanal ist von allen quasi der
sicherste. Aber die Windows Version ist hier auch nur minimal aktueller als die offiziellen normalen
Windows Builds. Die Release Preview Version ist auch die, die ich hier in diesem Video verwendet
habe und die heißt konkret Build 22631.23. Logisch. Hätte man sich denken können. Was ihr aber noch
bedenken müsst, wenn ihr Windows Insider aktiviert, dann müsst ihr erlauben, dass eure ganzen
Telemetriedaten zu Microsoft geschickt werden. Also wenn ihr das sonst abgeschaltet habt, ist
das vielleicht nicht so eine gute Idee für euch. Mein Fazit. Ich bin tatsächlich positiv überrascht,
dass Microsoft offenbar doch ein bisschen auf die Kundschaft hört und endlich diese
nervige Zwangsgruppierung in der Taskleistung. Ja, dem geht es genauso wie mir. Das ist das
einzige, was mich wirklich interessiert bei diesem Update. Ich finde die Texterkennung
des Snipping-Tools und die sehr stabilen Live-Untertitel wirklich super. Ah, das ist cool,
aber das Taskleisten-Gruppieren ist tatsächlich für mich das Spannende. Der juckt mich nicht. Der
geht mir so am Arsch vorbei, der Windows Copilot. Ja, das wundert mich nicht. Microsoft ist ja da
generell eher so am Sammeln. Also eher am mehr Sammeln als am zu wenig Sammeln. Es ist auch
witzig, wenn man Windows neu aufsetzt. Wir haben das ja letztens hier eben genau für 23h2 zum
Testen gemacht. Ich glaube die VM habe ich schon längst wieder gelöscht. Zumindest, ah ne, das war
noch der Proxmox-Test. Zumindest ist mir das da auch wieder aufgefallen beim Installer, dass du
nach dem Installieren erst mal gefühlt 5 Minuten anklicken musst. Nein, möchte ich nicht, möchte
ich nicht, möchte ich nicht, möchte ich nicht. Und in manchen Dialogen kannst du gar nicht sagen,
möchte ich nicht, sondern anstatt, du kannst sagen alles oder nur Basic schicken. Also du musst
manche Sachen zu Microsoft schicken. Also es ist alles schon etwas, naja, ziemlich für den Arsch.
Und was mich auch extrem abfuckt ist dieses, sie brauchen unbedingt ein Microsoft-Account. Das ist
so unglaublich unsinnig, für ein Desktop-System ein Windows-Account zu benötigen oder ein
Microsoft-Account zu benötigen. Ja, man kann das umgehen, ich weiß, wir haben es dann auch umgangen,
aber allein schon, dass es überhaupt eine Umgehung benötigt, finde ich bescheuert. Was haben wir denn
sonst als nächstes noch? Was ist das? Moment, was ist das? SuperjobsXXL, Fachinformatiker Systemintegration,
Welt der Wunder. Okay, wo bin ich hier gelandet? Hat schon mal exquisite Bewertungen. Das ist
bestimmt cringe, Alter. Oh, guck mal. Wobei, es ist nicht direkt mein Video, unser Video wird empfohlen.
Also, wen das interessiert, kann sich das tatsächlich mal angucken, wo wir uns ein bisschen
über die Physiausbildung und generell Karrierewege unterhalten. Okay, komm, wir gucken mal den
Anfang und dann entscheiden wir, ob es zu cringe ist oder geht.
Es wird schon gleich sehr laut gemacht.
SuperjobsXXL wurde Ihnen präsentiert von CWS Workwear.
Das ist ja fast schon Cocona-Musik. Hell yeah. Was will ich sehen, Alter? Sie sehen SuperjobsXXL.
Das ist Toast-Musik, ja. Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast. Die WM der Berufe. Ich ahne
Schlimmes, Leute. Ich ahne Schlimmes.
Mich hat es heute nach München verschlagen zur Firma Computer Center.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, heißt es nicht Computer Center,
sondern Computer Center. Nee, Computer Center, genau.
Heute darf ich den Arbeitsalltag von Nico Kelava begleiten. Und was der für ein Ausbildung macht,
das seht ihr jetzt im Einspieler.
Also die kenne ich, die kenne ich. Über den Namen mache ich mich schon seit Jahren lustig,
dass die Computer Center heißen. Ja, ich kenne die. Ja, die sind bekannt, aber der Name ist einfach.
Heute geht es um einen angehenden Computerfach.
Oh, Alter. Dice of Cringe. Dice of Cringe, Chat.
Hat man mit seinem Auto Startschwierigkeiten, ruft man den gelben Engel. Der Computer braucht
Hilfe von einem...
Alter, was ist denn das für ein PC im Hintergrund? 1998, let's grüßen, man.
Okay, immerhin kein Diskettenlaufwerk mehr drin, sondern noch ein SD-Kartenreader.
Ach man, das ist ein Beruf, etwas...
Und was macht der da überhaupt? Der sticht da aus in irgendwelche Lüfter gerade mit seinem
Schraubendreher rein. Wobei, das beste Bild in dieser Richtung ist ja immer noch Handwerk,
Lötkolben. Wobei das nicht so ernst zu nehmen ist jetzt. Das hier, das ist immer noch das beste
Bild. Wir sind Handwerker, wir können das. Aber das ist... Also, nur mal, um das... Dass man
das... Das ist, glaube ich, ein Fake-Bild. Das ist, glaube ich, ein Fake-Bild. Also,
jetzt nicht zu ernst nehmen. Ich glaube, das ist ein Fake-Bild. Also, das ist keine wirkliche
Werbung von denen. Das macht man so, wenn man besonders viel Kontrolle über die Spitze braucht,
wisst ihr? Wenn man besonders feinfühlig sein muss, dann nimmt man den möglichst... Wie bei
einem Stift möglichst weit unten. Das kommt bloß nicht auf die Idee, Leute. Das sind mindestens
250 Grad, eher 300, 305, je nachdem, was man da so lötet und was man da benutzt. Ob man was mit
Blei oder ohne Blei und... Zumindest, das wird heiß als Fuck, Alter, Leute. Ihr habt Brandblasen
fürs Leben. Deswegen finde ich Lötkolben äußerst nice, die... Die sowas... Die so hier sind zum
Beispiel, ja? Wieso? Das sind kleine Lötkolben. Die kannst du... Ich meine, die kannst du nicht hier
nehmen. Die kannst du da nehmen. Und die sind an so einem elastischen... An so einem elastischen
Kabel dran. Leider keine gescheiten Bilder hier. Die sind an so einem elastischen... Ja,
hier sieht man es gut. Die sind an einem elastischen Kabel dran. Das ist ein kleiner
Lötkolben an einem elastischen Kabel dran. Die finde ich persönlich sehr angenehm. Ja? Also,
die finde ich... Finde ich nice. CheesyPro, danke für den Sub. Das Ding finde ich... Finde ich
allgemein cool, die... Diese Lötstation hier. Welche Partei kam beim Wahl-O-Mat raus? FDP.
Kam raus. Ich glaube... Ich glaube, meine Top 5 waren... Meine... Also, Top 5 vom Wahl-O-Mat
waren, glaube ich, 1. Platz FDP, 2. Platz, glaube ich, Freie Wähler oder sowas, 3. Platz,
weiß ich, CDU, 4. Platz AfD, 5. Platz war irgendwie die... Keine Ahnung, sowas Merkwürdiges,
was ich noch nie gehört habe. So, weiter. Ja. SuperjobXXL, der Name ist schon... Ja,
wer kennt es nicht? Alter, diese Stockfotos, man. Wie alt ist der Beitrag? So top aktuell
sieht es nicht unbedingt aus. Na gut, ein Jahr alt, das hält sich noch... Das geht noch.
Druckerpatronen wechseln. Welcher Physi kennt es nicht, Druckerpatronen wechseln? Nee,
ehrlich gesagt kenne ich es nicht. Ich musste nie Druckerpatronen wechseln und ich finde auch,
das ist unter dem Niveau der meisten Leute, täglich der Druckerpatronen-Wechsler zu sein.
Interesse an Mathe braucht niemand, der Physi wird. Interesse an Basteln braucht man. Interesse
an Basteln, Interesse an Technik, Interesse an dem jeweiligen Gebiet, wo man unterwegs ist,
wenn man Anwendungsentwickler ist, natürlich auch am Programmieren, an Softwareentwicklung,
aber in Mathe nicht so wirklich. Es hilft, es schadet nicht, wenn einen das interessiert,
aber notwendig ist es nicht. Also nur weil ein Informatikstudium einen ziemlich großen
Mathe-Schwerpunkt hat, kann man das nicht auf die Ausbildung übertragen. Mathe für die Ausbildung
und für die ist komplett irrelevant. Voraussetzungen, natürlich Interesse an
Informatik und Mathematik. Sprachtalent kann zwar auch von Vorteil sein, aber mit Englisch oder
... Hä, den Zusammenhang kann ich nicht herstellen. Achso, ah, jetzt weiß ich,
wie du meinst. So, wach doch endlich auf, ihr Schlafschafe, meinst du so was. So
verschwörungsmäßig. Ja, das kann man tatsächlich so interpretieren, aber aufwachen könnte man auch
einfach wortwörtlich mit aufwachen, so aus dem Bett und aufstehen. Aber das verstehe ich schon,
dass das 2023 erstmal falsch interpretiert werden muss. Ja, genau. Die Leute, da hatte ich doch auch
mal vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen bei mir unter dem Video, unter dem Video, oder war das
nicht sogar hier im Stream? Irgendeiner, der dieses Schlafschaf-Video immer gepostet hat.
Da gibt es schon echt weird champige Leute. Weiter. Oder französisch hat die Programmiersprache zwar
auch von Vorteil sein. Moment, nochmal. Mathe, Blödsinn. Sprachtalent kann zwar auch von Vorteil
sein, aber mit Englisch oder Französisch hat die Programmiersprache nichts zu tun, wie du auf der
Berufsschule lernst. Bash Script und Python. Ist das so? Hat er gesagt, hat er gesagt, Bash oder
Batch? Auf der Berufsschule lernst. Bash Script. Ich glaube Batch, oder? Wenn Batch Script, ergibt
nicht wirklich Sinn, aber man erwartet jetzt ja auch nicht, dass der weiß, wovon er redet. Batch.
Ich hoffe, niemand muss Windows Batch noch machen heutzutage. Und Python. Ich bin jetzt in den
Büroräumen der Gemeinde gekommen. Python. Ich habe Nico direkt gefunden, zusammen mit deinem
Ausbildern Christian Meier. Ich bin richtig gespannt, was mich heute so am Tag erwartet.
In dem Bereich bin ich echt eine absolute Niete und ich freue mich, dass ihr mich da ein bisschen
mitnehmt. Aber bevor wir so richtig anfangen, möchte ich euch natürlich ein bisschen kennenlernen.
Das heißt, erzähl einfach mal kurz über dich. Was machst du hier in der Firma? Wie bist du
dazu gekommen? Also ich bin jetzt im zweiten Lehrjahr meiner Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker
Fachrichtung Systemintegration und bin ursprünglich zur Ausbildung gekommen, dadurch, dass ich schon
damals im jungen Alter sehr hohes Interesse hatte im technischen Bereich und mich da auch.
Nico macht das.
Während der Schulzeit noch halt privat sehr viel damit beschäftigt habe. Und so ist ein
kleiner Bastler, ein kleiner Frickler. So muss das sein. War ich auch früher. Waren wir wahrscheinlich
alle irgendwann. Und eins muss man sagen. Die Bastler, Leute, die gerne basteln und ausprobieren
und so, das sind auch immer noch die besten Leute. Im professionellen Umfeld kannst du
vielleicht nicht mehr alles basteln, was du denn möchtest. Aber einen gewissen Hang zum
ausprobieren und basteln brauchst du immer noch. Und das sind auch die besten Leute.
Wann gibt es ein Kruvi Scriptstream? Habe ich nicht vor. Ich habe mal eine größere
Sache gemacht. Das war so ein Konfluenz Plugin bei der bei der alten Firma noch in Kruvi. Habe
ich jetzt kein großes Bock, keinen großen Bock mehr drauf. Die Sprache geht durchaus in Ordnung,
aber sonnerlich toll fand ich das nicht.
Dann zum anderen gekommen, genau.
Wahnsinn. Und was ist deine Aufgabe jetzt so gerade während der Ausbildung? Um was
kümmerst du dich?
Also während der Ausbildung durchlaufe ich verschiedene Stationen. Also das wechselt.
Würdet ihr sagen, Physik ist beliebter als fachinformatische Anwendungsentwicklung? Nein,
ich würde sagen, es ist beides recht gefragt. Außerdem, also ich würde nicht sagen,
dass es da, ich meine, ich kenne jetzt keine Statistik, aber ich würde nicht sagen,
dass das eine großartig beliebter ist als das andere. Also Moment, meinst du jetzt Leute,
die das machen wollen oder Leute, die gesucht werden? Aber selbst da würde ich sagen,
geht eigentlich beides ganz gut klar. Außerdem spätestens, wenn du mit der Ausbildung fertig
bist, wirst du feststellen in der heutigen Zeit, klar, es gibt noch Entwicklungsteams und ja,
es gibt auch noch hauptsächlich Admenteams, aber es gibt immer mehr größere Überschneidungen.
Bei dir waren nur 90 Prozent Physis in der Klasse. Bei uns gab es eine Klasse für Physis
und eine Klasse, also es gab unterschiedliche Klassen für Anwendungsentwicklung und für
Physis. Also, die hatten wir einfach in Frankfurt genug. Also ganz ehrlich,
wer eine PHA-Ausbildung gemacht hat, muss keine Physi-Ausbildung mehr machen. Das kriegen die
Leute dann auch so hin, wenn sie sich ein bisschen... Wie gesagt, es gibt enorm viele
Überschneidungen, auch unabhängig von der Ausbildung, wenn man sich das mal anguckt,
diesen ganzen, allein schon den ganzen DevOps-Bereich, den es mittlerweile gibt. Ja,
und ich weiß, jetzt kommt Reddit. Actually, DevOps ist kein Beruf. DevOps ist eine Einstellung,
oder was auch immer die Leute auf Reddit immer gerne schreiben. Aber wenn ihr mal
in der Stellenbörse danach sucht, werdet ihr feststellen, doch, es ist ein Beruf mittlerweile.
Ja, zumindest, es gibt sehr viele Überschneidungen heute, wenn man sich das mal anschaut. Wie gesagt,
der ganze DevOps-Bereich, auch vieles im Cloud-Umfeld. Generell muss man sagen,
gerade im Cloud-Umfeld, wenn es dort um Infrastrukturautomatisierung geht,
wenn es um kontinuierliche Builds, Deployments, Rollouts geht und sowas, das hat viele
Überschneidungen, sowohl von AE als auch von Systemintegration. Und die Leute kommen auch
oftmals aus unterschiedlichen, unterschiedlichen Richtungen. Also ich meine, ich habe das jahrelang
gemacht und kam aus einer Physiausbildung. Und jetzt bei mir auf der neuen Arbeit haben wir einen,
der in der Position jetzt auch eine Weile ist, der ursprünglich, also der sich um
Automatisierungssachen und sowas kümmert, der war ursprünglich mal Java-Entwickler. Also insofern,
das geht aus beiden Richtungen. Und deswegen kann ich auch jedem nur empfehlen, es ist unglaublich
sinnvoll, ein bisschen über den Tellerrand rauszugucken. Also es hat keinen Sinn,
das kommt natürlich oft vor, aber es hat, finde ich, wenig Sinn, wenn man immer so auf die andere
Seite schimpft. Das ist ja beliebt, ja. Also es ist bei Entwicklern zum Beispiel sehr beliebt,
sich über irgendwelche Admins aufzuregen, so nach dem Motto, ah, warum kann man jetzt nicht einfach
mal und warum ist das? Und es ist auch sehr einfach, sich bei Admins darüber aufzuregen,
so nach dem Motto, ah, da können die nicht mal irgendwas entwickeln, was gescheit funktioniert
und so. Also ich kann allen nur empfehlen, sich mal ein bisschen so das anzugucken, was für Probleme
die andere Seite hat. Hilft einem oftmals, seine eigenen Aufgaben besser zu machen. Und es kommen
einfach bessere Lösungen am Ende raus, wenn sich auch mal ein Admin damit beschäftigt, was denn so
die Herausforderungen in der Softwareentwicklung sind, umgedreht. Sich auch mal, also zum Beispiel,
dass ein Admin sich auch mal die ein oder andere Programmiersprache anguckt. Nicht,
vielleicht aber ein bisschen über, wir machen ein bisschen, was in Bash rausgeht. Also wenn
Admin, Administratoren mal ordentlich was programmieren können, ist sicherlich nicht
verkehrt. Und umgedreht, auch wenn sich ein Anwendungsentwickler mal ein bisschen damit
beschäftigt, mit Linux, mit Cloud-Infrastruktur, mit seinen Anwendungen, Containerisieren, ist
auch viel gewonnen. Dann funktionieren beispielsweise die Health-Checks auf einmal,
die vorher ja total unsinnig gewesen sind. Das ist ein schönes Beispiel für, ja. Also,
wir haben mehrere Entwickler bei uns auf der Arbeit. Manch einer hat überhaupt keine Ahnung
von Infrastruktur. Und manche, merkt man, die haben sich durchaus mit Docker, Kubernetes und
Cloud-Sachen schon beschäftigt. Und ein Beispiel, woran man das ganz gut erkennt, ist Health-Checks
bei Anwendung. Chat-Gear, wer weiß, was ein Health-Check ist im Containerumfeld? Ich denke
mal, das wird den meisten noch irgendwas sagen. Also, im Kubernetesumfeld gibt es drei Health-Checks.
Es gibt eine Startup-Probe, es gibt eine Ready-Probe und es gibt eine Live-Probe. Und das
funktioniert, das ist für unterschiedliche Sachen da. Startup-Probe lassen wir mal durch.
Der Unterschied zwischen Ready- und Live-Probe ist, die, ich verwechsel die Dinge immer aus dem Kopf,
deswegen, es kann auch sein, dass es genau umgedreht ist, wie ich euch das jetzt erzähle.
Die Ready-Probe ist dafür da, dass wenn eine Anwendung gestartet ist und bereit ist,
Requests entgegenzunehmen, dass das signalisiert wird und Kubernetes nimmt dann die Anwendung
in das Service-Loadbalancing automatisch mit auf, wenn der Ready-Check okay ist. Geht der Ready-Check
auf Failed, dann wird die Anwendung aus dem Loadbalancing rausgenommen. Die Live-Probe ist
wieder, das ist was anderes. Wenn die Live-Probe fehlt, wird der Container neu gestartet. Das heißt,
ein Anwendungsentwickler muss sich überlegen, was sein Health-Check zurückgibt im Fall der Fälle.
Zum Beispiel, wenn die Anwendung intern gerade irgendwas macht und keine, was weiß ich, aus
irgendwelchen Gründen gerade keinen Background-Job läuft oder so, der abgearbeitet werden muss,
bis die nächsten Requests verarbeitet werden können. Irgendwas, einfach mal ausgedacht.
Dann sollte die Anwendung, und das dauert zwei Minuten, dann sollte die Anwendung vorher in
seinem Health-Check zurückliefern, ey, ich bin nicht ready zum Requests annehmen. Umgedreht,
mal angenommen, die Anwendung hat externe Abhängigkeiten zu irgendeiner Message-Queue
und die Message-Queue ist nicht da, dann sollte der Health-Check auf, also dann sollte die
Live-Probe fehlen, damit es, damit der Container neu gestartet wird und sich das beim Start neu
verbinden kann, zum Beispiel. Ja, weil man keinen eigenen Retry einbauen will. Und das habe ich
gemerkt, die Leute, die sich, also die Entwickler, die sich schon ein bisschen mit Cloud-Infrastruktur
beschäftigt haben, die kriegen das deutlich, deutlich besser hin, sinnvolle Health-Checks zu
implementieren versus die Leute, die gar keine Ahnung haben, weil die haben meistens den Health-Check,
der einfach immer True liefert, oder der, den es gar nicht gibt. Hat einfach gar keinen Health-Check.
Und daran sieht man, das ist ein schönes Beispiel, es bringt sich, bringt immer was,
ein bisschen über den Tellerrand rauszugucken. Als Admin vielleicht mal die ein oder andere
Programmieraufgabe, Programmiersprache lernen und auch ein paar kleinere Projekte machen,
was natürlich auch hilft für interne Automatisierung, interne Tools,
so einfach in der Administration und als Anwendungsentwickler auch mal gucken,
okay, worauf läuft der ganze Kram? Ist schon sinnvoll. So, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, weiter, weiter zu Nico.
Und da laufe ich verschiedene Stationen, also das wechselt dann regelmäßig und da ist man dann in
verschiedenen Kundensituationen vor Ort. Oh, vor Ort, Endkunde, hör mal auf. Nico, please.
Und kriegt halt einen guten Überblick, was alles so geschieht und was es für Möglichkeiten noch
gibt, wo man gerne hin möchte. Und du als dein Ausbilder, bist du genauso gestartet? Warst du auch
schon immer technikinteressiert oder war das damals noch gar nicht so? Bei mir früher gab es das alles noch gar nicht.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also ich bin 15 Jahre in der Firma jetzt, aber tatsächlich, nein, das ist nicht so gestartet.
Also ich bin gelernter Maler. Ach, wirklich? Wie ich? Ja. Und habe dann auch noch eine Ausbildung als
Energieanlagen-Elektroniker gemacht und bin danach zur Polizei gegangen. Okay, der hat schon einiges durch.
War quasi Streifenpolizist. Wahnsinn. Und ja, irgendwann dann durch diverse weitere Schulungen und natürlich auch...
Was möchten Sie machen? Ja, einmal alles. Privates Interesse, in die Technik gerutscht und dann bei Computercenter
eben angefangen und meine Zeit hier natürlich genutzt, um mich nach heute weiterzubilden.
Was mich natürlich mega interessiert, wo darf ich denn heute ein bisschen reinschnuppern? Wo nehmt ihr mich denn so ein bisschen mit in deinen Arbeitsalltag?
Also ich würde sagen, dass wir jetzt ja morgen erst mal damit beginnen, meine Präsentation, die ich für die neuen Azubis vorbereite, mal durchgehen.
Das ist eine längere Präsentation, da werden wir uns nochmal so einen kleinen Zwischenstand anschauen und dann würden wir...
Ich hoffe... Ich hoffe, er sagt nicht meinen Triggerspruch am Ende. Vielen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Dann schauen wir da erst mal rein und in der Zeit, wo wir jetzt den Platz wechseln zu seinem Arbeitsplatz, gibt es einen kleinen Einspieler über die Firma und da schaut ihr mal, was da überhaupt dahinter steckt.
Der Name macht mich immer noch fertig, seit ich ihn kenne.
Seit ich ihn das erste Mal gelesen habe. Ich meine, hätten sie nicht das Center auch noch ein A hintendran machen können, dann wäre es wenigstens das Computacenter gewesen.
...ist ein führender, unabhängiger Anbieter von IT-Infrastrukturservices und Lösungen für große...
Oh, was haben wir denn hier? Ist das ein Plate oder sowas? Was bin ich hier sehend? Ja, sowas.
Ja, nee, ist kein Plate, das ist irgendein IHE-Server. Für ein Plate ist das viel zu groß.
Und da haben wir eine 10G-Karte, vielleicht? Man weiß es nicht. SFP-Ports, SFP-Plus-Ports, man erkennt es nicht so genau.
Oh nee, 1000 hat der hier nur. Ah gut, das sind ja alles normale...
...Unternehmen sowie...
Können wir da reininterpretieren, Chatge? Können wir anhand der blauen Schraube reininterpretieren, dass das eine IBM-Kiste ist?
Ich finde, irgendwie sieht das ein bisschen... Oh, Lenovo ist es ja heute wahrscheinlich.
Ich finde, das ganze Ding da unten sieht ein bisschen nach IBM aus, vom Style her.
Aber das kann auch einfach täuschen und was ganz anderes sein.
...und Lösungen für Großunternehmen... Ist nur ein Stockfoto, ja und?
...Organisationen des öffentlichen Sektors. Weltweit arbeiten in der Firma 17.000 Beschäftigte, davon 6.700 in 25 Standorten in Deutschland und am Haupt...
Das gibt es in Frankfurt auch. In Frankfurt gibt es auch ein Computercenter.
...und in 70 Ländern werden unterstützt bei der Beschaffung, Transformation und Verwaltung ihrer IT-Infrastruktur...
Alter, den Sprecher haben sie auch die Aufgabe gestellt. Erzähl das mal so möglichst spannend und unspektakulär wie irgendwie möglich.
...sowie bei ihrer digitalen...
Oh, da wollen sie wieder zeigen, wie hip sie sind.
...Umgestaltung...
Also bei Computercenter bilden wir jedes Jahr eine hohe Anzahl von Auszubildenden und Dualstudierenden aus.
Jetzt im Oktober haben wir zum Beispiel insgesamt deutschlandweit 220 Auszubildende und Dualstudierende.
Okay, daran erkennt man, der Beitrag ist neuer. Das ist nicht wieder so ein Beitrag, wie wir letztens hatten, der irgendwie sieben Jahre alt ist und als neu verkauft wird.
Sonst würdet ihr nicht Studierende sagen.
...Standorten. Mit diesem Engagement zeigen wir ja, dass uns Ausbildung sehr wichtig ist. Wir stehen voll und ganz hinter dem dualen System der Ausbildung.
Das heißt, ein großer Teil der Ausbildung findet theoretisch statt in der Berufsschule und der andere Teil praktisch...
Ah, du meinst, es war Fiber Channel? Das könnte auch sein.
...Betrieb und das ist halt eine hervorragende Möglichkeit für die Auszubildenden, wirklich verschiedene Bereiche kennenzulernen und zu schauen, wo sind ihre Fähigkeiten,
welche Tätigkeiten machen ihnen Spaß, wo liegen ihre Interessen, um so dann wirklich in das Berufsleben starten zu können.
Wir sind jetzt direkt bei der ersten Tagesaufgabe oder Teilaufgabe. Du hast gesagt, du bereitest eine Präsentation für die neuen Azubis vor.
Pixel versus Vector.
Wie ist das in der Ausbildung, dass du Präsentationen hältst oder ist das jetzt nur was ganz Spontanes, was du jetzt mal kurz machen musst?
Ne, das machen wir eigentlich in der Firma öfter so, dass wir sozusagen dem ersten...
Alter, jetzt rückt euch doch mal nicht so auf die Pelle, Mann. Musst ihr da wirklich drei Leute in die Ecke zwängen?
...Lehrjahr-Workshops anbieten, wo sie dann teilnehmen können.
Die gehen dann auch über einen Arbeitstag und da werden denen halt Themen näher gebracht, um sie auch zu inspirieren und einfach so ein allgemeines technisches Wissen näher zu bringen.
Warum habt ihr damit angefangen, eure Azubis so Präsentationstage machen zu lassen?
Weil man sich gedacht hat, das muss ein Azubi machen, weil man sich das von anderen abgeguckt hat, höchstwahrscheinlich.
Wir haben ja regelmäßig so Auszubildende, die schon ein bisschen weiter sind fachlich.
Ich finde das aber an sich gar nicht verkehrt, wenn man ab und zu mal ein paar Sachen vorstellen muss, weil man lernt an der Stelle eine ganz wichtige Sache.
Tolle Sachen machen alleine reicht nicht.
Es ist besser, man macht nur halb so viel tolle Sachen und die andere Hälfte der Zeit redet man darüber, was für tolle Sachen man gemacht hat, anstatt die zweite Hälfte weiterhin tolle Sachen zu machen.
Also das ist durchaus sinnig.
Wir vermitteln an die neuen Auszubildenden, die also quasi in der Zeit ein bisschen davor sind.
Zum einen fördert das so ein bisschen das Miteinander der Azubis und zum anderen festigen natürlich die, die es den anderen Azubis erklären, nochmal ihren eigenen Wissensstand.
Das stimmt voll. Sobald du eine Sache ordentlich erklären kannst, hast du es meistens verstanden.
Soll er hier natürlich ein bisschen so seine Fähigkeiten der Präsentation üben und sowohl die Erstellung als auch das Halten.
Also am besten ist, ich finde es hat auch wenig Sinn, wenn man irgendeinen Müll aufbaust, so ist es geil.
Ich finde am besten ist, wenn man was cooles gemacht hat, das dann auch dementsprechend so zu verkaufen.
Aber insgesamt ist es enorm wichtig, dass das was man gemacht hat, dass man das in irgendeiner Art und Weise gut verkauft im Anschluss.
Ich bin gespannt, was du alles da schon vorbereitet hast.
Ich würde dann hier einfach mit dem neuen Kapitel anfangen, das ich jetzt dazu gemacht habe, weil es wirklich eine lange Präsentation auch ist.
Und da geht es jetzt um den Unterschied von Pixel und Vektoren.
Da geht es darum, was der Unterschied zwischen Pixel und Vektoren sind, also in verschiedenen Dateiformaten.
Genau, dann schauen wir uns hier einmal an, nach welchen Kriterien wir das Ganze dann...
Ob das Dateiformate sind, kann man sich jetzt darüber streiten, aber es ist klar, was er meint.
Es wäre natürlich erstmal sinnvoll, den prinzipiellen Unterschied zu erklären zwischen Vektorformaten und Pixelformaten.
Also das in den Pixelformaten, quasi jeder einzelne Bildpunkt genau, also feste Auflösung, jeder einzelne Bildpunkt ist halt eine Farbe.
Und bei Vektor ist es halt die Form mathematisch beschrieben.
Dementsprechend kannst du Vektordateien halt auch skalieren, wie du willst.
Geht es um SVG und PNG?
Naja, eigentlich geht es hauptsächlich erstmal darum, was der Unterschied zwischen Vektor und Pixel ist.
Bewerten werden, was der Vorteil und Nachteil ist.
Einmal die Bildgröße, was da die Unterschiede sind, der Dateigröße,
welche Freiheiten das jeweilige Dateiformat halt bieten wird.
Und dann macht man auch eine kleine Zusammenfassung.
Hier haben wir jetzt so ein Beispielbild für eine normale Bildaufnahme, wie man sie mit dem Handy oder einer Kamera machen könnte.
So was kriegst du halt nicht unbedingt gut in Vektor.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal, wenn wir da weiter reinzoomen...
Dann wird es pixelig.
...dass das Bild deutlich verpixelt wird.
Das ist der Klassiker.
Genau, und darauf will ich halt eingehen, dass man hier halt sieht, das ist jetzt sozusagen eine normale Bildaufnahme.
Ein gutes Beispiel.
Eine sozusagen Pixeldatei oder Rasterdatei.
Wenn wir uns das jetzt hier nochmal anschauen, dann haben wir jetzt auf der linken Seite eine Vektordatei.
Hat er auch schön gemacht mit dem Ranzoomen und so, finde ich gut gemacht.
Pixel- oder auch Rasterdatei genannt, daneben.
Schicke Presentation.
Mit was hat er die erstellt?
Sehen wir hier, dass bei der Vektordatei keine Punkte einzeln sind, sondern Formen und Linien.
Sozusagen einzelne Farbflächen, auch wenn ich jetzt Überschneidungen hätte.
Richtig, ja.
Und jetzt schauen wir mal rüber.
Schick, gefällt mir, finde ich gut gemacht.
Wir gehen weiter rein und es wird nur noch unschärfer.
Das heißt, wir arbeiten heute an der Präsentation weiter oder was ist der weitere Tagesablauf?
Na ja, also Vormittag haben wir uns jetzt hier dafür auch Zeit genommen.
Oh, der schmatzt immer so.
Es gibt Leute, die haben diese Angewohnheit.
Mich nervt das immer übelst, wenn so beim, ich nenne es so, der Denkschmatzer.
So, was sage ich denn jetzt?
Zuhause werden wir dann aber natürlich auch in den Alltag übergehen ein bisschen.
Das heißt, er wird im Bereich des Rechenzentrums Monitoringaufgaben übernehmen.
Oh, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Das wird der weitere Tagesablauf auch für ihn für heute natürlich sein.
Noch ein bisschen der olle Nagios rausgeholt.
Dann freue ich mich schon drauf, was mich da in dem Bereich erwartet.
Und jetzt gibt es erstmal einen kleinen Einspieler über die Historie des Berufs.
Das Berufsbild des Fachinformatikers in Deutschland wurde am 1. August 2020 im Rahmen einer modernisierten
Ausbildungsordnung aktualisiert.
Es gibt jetzt nicht nur zwei Physis, es gibt jetzt vier Physi-Berufe.
Es gibt Fachinformatik, Anwendungsentwicklung, Systemintegration,
dann irgendwie Vernetzung und Dings, Bums, Zeug und keine Ahnung.
Und Datenanalyse gibt es dann noch, glaube ich.
Die neuen Berufe kenne ich nicht.
Ich kenne auch legit niemand, der diese neuen Berufe anbietet oder macht.
Themen IT-Sicherheit und Datenschutz wurden deutlich ausgebaut.
Genau so sehen die zwei typischen Physis aus im Rechenzentrum.
Richtig nice trainiert im Anzug mit Krawatte und Zeigen auf einem Surfer.
Und mit einem MacBook.
Typisches Bild zweier Physis im Rechenzentrum.
...wurden deutlich ausgebaut und die sozialen und personalen Kompetenzen rückten stärker in den Mittelpunkt.
Wo wir gerade beim Bild Pixel versus Vektorgrafik waren.
...Berufe im Bereich der Informations- und Telekommunikationstechnik,
Datenverarbeitungskaufmann, Operator oder Programmierer.
Vor gut 25 Jahren wurden die EDV-Berufe allesamt an Großrechnern eingesetzt.
Der PC kam erst 1981 in die Firmen.
Ordentlicher Haust!
Vernetzungen erst in den Jahren darauf.
Wupp, wupp, wupp.
Zu jedem Arbeitsalltag gehört natürlich auch irgendwie eine gute Mittagspause.
Und wir sitzen deshalb gerade schon mit ein paar Kollegen zusammen.
Moment, machen die ernsthaft? Ich wollte gerade sagen, jetzt kommt Sellout oder was?
Ich freue mich richtig immer in solchen Situationen zu sitzen.
Ich freue mich immer in solchen Situationen zu sitzen. Ich nicht.
Freut sich irgendjemand auf solche gezwungenen Situationen, man?
Die anderen Mitarbeiter mal kennenzulernen.
Stimmt. Und außerdem, wo ist der gratis Obstkorb, man?
Mir ist immer wichtig, was macht ihr überhaupt in der Firma?
Wie seid ihr hergekommen und macht ihr das gleiche wie die zwei?
Oder einfach mal drauf los erzählen?
Ich bin jetzt seit 30 Jahren bei Computercenter und habe als Techniker begonnen.
Also ungefähr das, was der Nico mal werden möchte.
Bin jetzt aber aktuell als Teamleiter.
Das heißt, ich habe die Personalverantwortung für 25 Technik- und Systemingenieure.
Und bin nebenbei auch noch Ausbilder.
Ja, die sitzen alle übelst nah beieinander. Da würde ich schon wieder Zustände bekommen.
Genau, das macht viel Spaß.
Breit gestaffelt.
Hört sich spannend an.
In 30 Jahren muss ja auch was passieren.
Man sollte nicht auf der Stelle stehen bleiben.
Aber ich glaube, das Unternehmen ist so vielfältig, was ich bis jetzt mitbekommen habe.
Und was macht ihr?
Ich muss mal kurz ein bisschen skippen.
Also ich bin in der Personalanteilung.
Oh ne, HR ist auch am Start. Jetzt ist es vorbei.
Bei uns nennt sich das HR Senior Consulting, weil wir ja doch sehr international sind.
Und ich betreue, falls Betreuung erforderlich ist, die Teamleiter, wenn es um verschiedene knifflige arbeitsrechtliche Themen geht.
Aber wir verbringen regelmäßig auch die Mittagspause miteinander.
Wir haben dich auf jeden Fall schon mal gehört.
Ja, genau.
In dem Statement davor. Aber du kannst dich trotzdem nochmal vorstellen.
Was? HR Consulting? Moment. Die wird dann gefragt, wenn... Hä? Was auch immer.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ich bin auch ganz klassisch im Personal angesiedelt. Kümmer mich hier auch um das Thema Ausbildung.
Alles von der Einstellung bis zum Übertritt, viel was dahinter läuft an Konzeption.
Bin auch die Personalverantwortliche für die Azubis und bin bei den fachlichen Themen eigentlich raus.
Dafür habe ich ja unsere Ausbilder.
Dafür gibt es dann die Ausbildungsstudie.
Genau. Und auch den Christian, den ihr auch schon kennt.
Das wirkt so gezwungen alles.
Und mich dann halt einfach um die fachliche Betreuung der Azubis kümmert.
Hast du schon eine Abteilung gefunden, wo du sagst, da fühle ich mich schon mega wohl?
Oder sagst du, ich lasse mir noch... Sag jetzt bloß nicht Windows.
Alles offen bis zum Ende. Mal schauen, was ich jetzt noch so entdecken darf im nächsten Jahr.
Ja, also bis jetzt habe ich mich gut zurecht gefunden in allen Abteilungen und überall.
Oh, das ist diplomatische Antwort. Das muss er jetzt sagen, weil sein Chef dabei ist.
Mit Kollegen, mit denen man sich auch gut versteht. Auch privat auch zum Teil gut versteht.
Aber bei mir ist es ja jetzt... Ich bin ja noch im zweiten Lehrjahr.
Wäre das jetzt noch ein bisschen zu früh zu sagen, wo ich mich jetzt endgültig so ansiedeln möchte.
Ja, zumindest mal zu wissen, was einem passt so.
Erst nochmal das große, breite Feld dann abgeben.
Genau. Alles inspizieren und dann schauen, wo es lang geht.
Ich finde es auch schön, wenn man sich es wirklich offen lassen kann und dann am Ende halt sagt,
okay, das ist die Abteilung, wie ich sein möchte.
Aber du kannst ja auch noch weiter... Wäre Ausbilder was für dich?
Die jeweilige Abteilung muss wahrscheinlich auch sagen, den hätten wir gerne.
Im Moment vorstellen?
Im Moment noch nicht, aber...
Wie alt er ist? Keine Ahnung. Gab es nicht.
Aber mal ganz davon abgesehen, ist es auch wurscht.
Du kannst auch mit 30 noch eine Ausbildung machen heutzutage. Das ist alles kein Ding.
Das kann immer noch mal kommen.
Okay, kommt da noch irgendwas?
Ich kann mich so unterstützen, weil ihr sagt...
Bestimmt möchtest du auch nicht...
Ich scrolle mal ein bisschen vor. Ich will eigentlich wissen, was jetzt noch mit Moni...
Ja, okay. Geht weiter.
...weiter voranschreitet, wird der Beruf des Fachinformatikers für System...
Das juckt mich auch nicht.
SAP.
Paintschamp.
Die haben hier einfach random irgendwelche Sachen auf die Tafel geschrieben, oder?
...Bildungsmöglichkeiten. Kann man sich zudem sehr gut auf einen Aufgabenbereich spezialisieren.
Aber auch im Nehmen spannend...
...verkabelt.
Es benötigt wird, um auf den Kunden zugleich...
...dass sie als...
Stand da gerade Fettverbrennung?
Habe ich da gerade Fettverbrennung gelesen?
...dass sie als komplexe Systeme den speziellen Kundenanforderungen gerecht werden.
Was auch immer.
Wir sind jetzt gerade im Azubi-Büro.
Ah, okay. Interessant, interessant.
Was haben wir denn da hinten?
Ist das...
Ist das PRTG?
Was ist denn das? Jetzt bin ich da sehend, Chat.
Okay, da sind die für mich schon mal raus, Alter.
Windows-Krempel.
...gerecht werden.
Wir sind jetzt gerade im Azubi-Büro.
Finde ich unglaublich blöde, ein Azubi-Büro.
Ich fände es viel sinnvoller, wenn die Azubis dabei sind.
So ein für sich losgelöstes Azubi-Büro ist so ein...
Ja, finde ich blöd.
Kann man sich hier nicht drüber streiten.
Und hier hat Nico ja gerade eine Aufgabe.
Vielleicht nimmst du mich gerade kurz mit, was jetzt genau seine Aufgabe gerade ist.
Wir können natürlich nicht in der Realität gewisse Sachen üben.
Warum?
Also gerade wenn es um Störfälle oder solche Sachen geht beim Kunden.
Sehr gut.
Deswegen üben wir solche Szenarien innerhalb der Firma, in unseren eigenen vier Wänden,
wo wir eben solche Sachen simulieren können,
damit unser Mitarbeiter, oder in dem Fall der Nico,
dann vor Ort auch wirklich fit ist für solche Sachen.
Hat das denn jetzt schon was mit dem Bildschirm daneben zu tun?
Also ist das dann schon sowas, was er dann vor sich hat?
Genau, das ist quasi jetzt hier ein Beispiel auch für ein typisches Monitoring-System,
wo man diverse Systeme sieht, die im Rechenzentrum laufen.
Und wir haben für ihn ein...
Ja, also ich weiß nicht, ob PRTG taugt.
Ich glaube schon, weil es benutzen nicht umsonst viele.
Aber wenn irgendein Laden PRTG benutzt,
heißt das für mich immer schon, die sind sehr Windows-zentriert.
Und da hätte ich schon mal keinen Bock drauf.
Einen Störfall auch vorbereitet.
Und das ist ja Microsoft-zentriert.
Jetzt eine der Komponenten vom Netz genommen wird und somit einen Alarm auslöst.
Und ja, Nicos Aufgabe ist es halt in dieser Übung zum Beispiel zu erkennen,
ja okay, wo muss ich hin?
Was ist das Gerät und was sind die Maßnahmen, um es wieder in den Betrieb zu nehmen?
Und das wäre dann auch wie beim Kunden.
Er wäre vor Ort beim Kunden, auf einmal passiert irgendwas
und seine Aufgabe ist es, das so schnell wie möglich wieder zu lösen.
Eins zu eins.
Damit der Kunde arbeiten kann.
Genau.
Okay.
Hast du so Störfälle schon öfter bearbeitet
oder ist das jetzt erst so ein neuerer Teil deiner Ausbildung?
Nee, tatsächlich beginnt das jetzt erst mit dem Monitoring.
Die tun ja gerade so, als wäre der Kern des ganzen das Monitoring-Systems.
Das Kern des Problems bei so etwas ist nicht, dass man auf das Monitoring guckt
und feststellt, ho, da wird was rot und dann ist es immer das gleiche,
was man machen muss, dass es wieder grün wird.
Dieses, huch, es wird ja rot, ist eigentlich nur so, ach ja, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Und das eigentliche Problem ist ja dann, okay, was ist denn kaputt?
Es gibt ja auch durchaus genug Störungen, wo im Monitoring so direkt gar nichts zu sehen ist.
Kann man sagen, vielleicht nicht richtig gemonitort,
aber so ein kompletter Systemausfall ist ja nun wirklich schon das seltenste.
Egal, ordentliches Monitoring ist natürlich trotzdem wichtig.
Bei mir und genau, deswegen bin ich auch gespannt, was da jetzt bei rumkommen wird.
Wir haben ja den Ausbilder dabei im Notfall, muss er erst richten und dir alles zeigen,
dann kannst du es dir einmal angucken.
Das ist ja genau das, was ich sage, das ist verkehrt.
Du kannst nie auf alle Fehlerfälle vorbereitet sein.
Du kannst Ahnung haben von einem Themengebiet und dann selbst im Fall der Fälle,
wenn was kaputt geht, dahinter kommen, was eigentlich kaputt ist.
Aber so dieses, aha, im Monitoring wird was rot und so, so,
das ist jetzt immer exakt das gleiche, was ich machen muss, dass es wieder grün ist.
Das ist halt komplett verkehrt.
Okay.
Genau, ja, hier können wir jetzt eigentlich auch schon sehen.
Ein Ping!
Eigentlich war da zuvor ein grüner Haken, das heißt, das wäre jetzt zum Beispiel noch grün.
Hier sehen wir jetzt, dass diese Verbindung verloren gegangen ist.
Und deine Aufgabe ist es jetzt, im Rechenzentrum nach dem Rechten zu sehen.
Dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir mal ins Rechenzentrum und gucken, was da passiert.
Also, seriously, ich verstehe, das ist für den Beitrag gemacht und so.
Ja, und ich will nicht sagen, dass das nicht vorkommt,
aber kompletter Serverausfall ist ein ganz, ganz kleiner Teil der Fehlerfälle.
Wir sind jetzt direkt im Data Center.
Im Data Center von Computer Center.
Ist auch ordentlich Lautstärke, ist ein richtig schöner Arbeitsplatz.
Was ist jetzt deine Aufgabe?
Für mich ist hier Kabelsalat, wobei es sehr geordneter Kabelsalat ist.
Das ist ja noch vollkommen, das ist ja noch echt.
Also, da habe ich schon Schlimmeres gesehen.
Was ist das überhaupt für eine Fehlermeldung?
Also, eins der Geräte, genau genommen der Alarmsensor, hat die Verbindung verloren.
Hey, schönes Konsolenkabel rein.
Das ist auch das, was wir auf dem Monitor vorher gesehen haben.
Ja.
Okay, hat da irgendjemand den Port runtergefahren, um lustig zu sein?
Ich weiß anhand der Beschreibung, die wir auf dem Monitor gesehen haben,
weiß er ungefähr, wo das ist.
Das heißt, er weiß schon, an welches Gerät er ran muss.
Allerdings muss er jetzt natürlich noch feststellen,
welche dieser Leitungen die Verbindung tatsächlich verloren hat.
Okay.
Muss ich dazu natürlich auf das Gerät einloggen
und muss diverse Diagnosen laufen lassen,
um zu sehen, wo die Verbindung weg ist und die natürlich auch wieder herrscht.
Das heißt, in seinem aktuellen Lernprozess ist er jetzt schon so weit,
dass er diese Fehlermeldung grob analysieren kann.
Okay.
Das ist sehr Business-Enterprise-mäßig Werbevideo jetzt halt gemacht.
Das ist cool.
Oder irgendwie fachmännisch klingt oder so.
Im Monitoring zu sehen, System antwortet nicht mehr.
System ist... Server ist down.
Das ist...
Das ist nicht schon gleich die Beschreibung dafür, was gemacht werden muss.
Außerdem ist das eines der seltensten Fälle, dass das ganze System weg ist.
Aber noch nicht zu 100 Prozent.
Also einen Port hochfahren kann der Nico garantiert.
Der macht den Eindruck, als weiß er, was er treibt.
Der kann garantiert einen Port hochfahren.
Den Teil kann er wahrscheinlich schon alleine lösen.
Allerdings noch nicht so sicher, dass man jetzt sagen könnte,
man könnte in ein reales Umfeld zum Kunden...
Also einen Port hochfahren.
Ich habe da so viel Vertrauen in den Nico, dass er das hinkriegt.
Und wahrscheinlich würde er das auch easy hinkriegen,
wenn nicht der Ausbilder neben ihm stehen würde.
Wahrscheinlich kriegt er das auch easy hin.
Was hast du jetzt gemacht? Das blaue Kabel hast du angeschlossen.
Das ist ein Konsolenkabel.
Wir haben uns jetzt mit dem Konsolenkabel angeschlossen,
damit wir hier auf die Benutzeroberfläche von dem Switch zugreifen können.
Warum muss das ein Windows-Notebook sein?
Um hier zu schauen, wo jetzt eigentlich das Problem ist
und wieso er nicht mehr ansprechbar ist.
Ich habe jetzt ehrlich gesagt nichts gesehen.
Im Prinzip wird er gucken, ob irgendjemand lustig war
und den Port runtergefahren hat.
Und mal ganz abgesehen davon,
dafür musst du doch nicht ins Rechenzentrum per Konsolenkabel.
Aber gut, ich gette das schon, das ist für den Film halt.
Zeig mir hoffentlich, Christian, wie wir da am besten vorgehen,
eigentlich solltest du einen Teil schon wissen.
Ich mag den Ausbilder nicht.
Tatsächlich suchen wir uns jetzt erstmal heraus,
welches der Interface denn aktuell nicht funktioniert.
Leute, ich hatte recht.
Irgendeiner war lustig und hat den Port runtergefahren.
Moment, Cisco Port hochfahren,
das war doch die Logik von No Shutdown ist Port hochfahren, gell?
Ich habe mal einen CCNA gemacht vor 15 Jahren.
Mehr weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ach so, und EN am Anfang.
Und EN.
Das ist eine Sache, die kriege ich im Kopf noch zusammen.
Man geht auf eine Cisco-Kiste drauf,
als erstes gibt man EN ein für Enable
und dann muss man Conf T, nee, das war was anderes, gell?
Und dann sagt man No Shutdown.
War Conf T?
Ich habe es doch tatsächlich noch irgendwo ein bisschen im Kopf drin.
Conf T?
Und dann muss man irgendwie in die Port-Config, ja?
Und dann muss man in die Port-Config
und dann sagt man No Shutdown.
Also ein bisschen was ist hängen geblieben, Leute.
Ein bisschen was ist hängen geblieben.
Der Befehl dafür ist,
genau, Show Interface und den Status.
Erstmal Putty Fullscreen.
Wir haben damals immer Minicom verwendet,
aber wir hatten auch das Glück,
kein ekeliges Windows-Notebook verwenden zu müssen,
sondern wir hatten noch so ein richtig fettes,
ich weiß noch damals,
T50?
Gab es da so was?
So ein ganz fettes?
Ja, so ein richtig dickes, genau.
So ein richtig dickes mit Metallscharnieren.
Und da hatten wir Ubuntu, was wird denn das sein?
804 oder so drauf.
Und das wurde seit Jahren, das wurde jahrelang nicht aktualisiert.
Das hat wahrscheinlich heute immer noch Ubuntu 804 drauf.
Das liegt wahrscheinlich auch immer noch im gleichen Schrank.
Also als ich weg bin, lag das noch da.
Und jetzt ein Dreivierteljahr später,
wird es wahrscheinlich immer noch da liegen.
Und da gab es nur Minicom drauf, also installiert.
Und das hat gereicht.
Das war halt unser Konsolen-Notebook.
Das musste nicht geupdatet werden.
Ich meine, heute weiß ich nicht,
ob man noch Minicom verwendet,
aber das war halt was für serielle Verbindungen.
Jetzt mal als Halbwisser,
gibt es nicht eine Möglichkeit,
ohne Konsolen, ohne den Befehl aufs Kleinste zu wissen?
Ja doch, Google benutzen.
Oder du drückst auf der Command-Line Fragezeichen.
Unter Linux würde ich Tab, Tab drücken,
dann zur Auto, AutoComplete.
Unter Basisco drückst du immer Fragezeichen,
dass du siehst, was es noch für Möglichkeiten gibt,
dein Kommando zu vervollständigen.
Deswegen, Google plus sich ein bisschen Basic-mäßig
auf dem System auskennen,
sodass man sich zusammenreiben kann, was man machen muss.
Aber für grundlegende Sachen,
wie Port hochfahren und sowas,
das weiß man nach einer Zeit eigentlich.
Aber warum kein GUI?
Es gibt für einige Switches
tatsächlich mittlerweile Web-Interfaces.
Aber ich weiß nicht,
ich habe wirklich sehr lange
nicht mehr großartig mit Netzwerk-Hardware gemacht.
Also es gibt durchaus mittlerweile,
glaube ich, sogar Cisco-Switche,
die Konfigurations-UIs haben.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus,
dass die meisten Cisco-Switche heute nach wie vor
auch über CLI administriert werden.
Das hat einfach den riesen Vorteil,
dass du sehr viel Funktionalität einbauen kannst,
wo du halt ansonsten den UI für bauen müsstest.
Also ich stelle es mir unglaublich schwierig vor,
die gesamte Funktionalität in einem UI abzubilden.
Und das Remote-Administrieren ist halt deutlich einfacher
über CLI als über einen UI.
Überleg dir mal, du hast,
also normalerweise ist es ja so,
du hast irgendwo einen Switch stehen.
Sagen wir mal, du sitzt in Frankfurt
und der Switch steht in London.
Du kommst ja nicht direkt da drauf,
nicht unbedingt direkt da drauf.
So, UI-mäßig bräuchtest du jetzt irgendeine,
tja, frag mich nicht,
irgendeine Kiste am Standort stehen.
Da müsstest du dann X-Forwarding machen,
RDP oder was auch immer.
Da drüber dann irgendeinen Browser
und hoffen, dass im Web-Interface
das alles lagfrei funktioniert.
Vielleicht brauchst du noch irgendeinen UI,
musst dich da hinkonnekten.
Weiß nicht, ich find's,
es ist ähnlich wie SSH versus RDP.
Ich find's mit SSH einfach um so vielen Längen angenehmer,
als zu klicken mit RDP.
Und ein weiterer Riesenvorteil von CLI versus UI,
gut, natürlich kann man sagen,
warum nicht beides, ja?
Das ist gut, wenn es ein ordentliches UI gibt,
warum nicht?
Aber ein Riesenvorteil von CLI versus UI ist,
dass du es viel, viel einfacher,
einfacher ist gar nicht das richtige Wort für,
umwelten einfacher automatisieren kannst
und auch massenmäßig administrieren kannst
als UI-Geklicke.
Stell dir mal vor,
du musst ein Setting ändern auf 150 Switchen.
Das ist über einen Terminal,
über Terminal, irgendeine Schleife, CLI,
wahrscheinlich innerhalb von zwei Minuten erledigt.
UI bist du erstmal den ganzen Tag am klicken.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich sagen,
hey, warum gibt es nicht einfach eine gute CLI und ein gutes UI?
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich,
ich denke die meisten Leute,
die das professionell machen,
die schätzen die CLI-Bedienung
mehr als ein Webinterface
mit einer halbherzig implementierten UI.
Weil alle Features,
die du CLI-mäßig an dem Switch einstellen kannst,
wirst du nicht ins UI kriegen.
Und wenn doch,
dann sieht das UI ähnlich hässlich aus wie bei MikroTik.
Ja, du kannst auch einfach mitloggen,
was du aufgeschrieben hast.
Ja, genau.
Du kannst auch die Config einfach copy-pasten.
Und wie war das bei Cisco nochmal?
Copy, copy, save, run?
Nee, copy, run, start oder sowas?
Copy, run, boot?
Nee, copy, run, start.
Genau, copy, run, start.
Ihr seht, für einzelne Sachen sind hängen geblieben.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal fertig.
Okay, Nico, Port hochfahren, let's go!
Status und sehen, schauen uns an,
wo das Problem tatsächlich liegt.
Und was meinst du, wo das liegt?
Also, das ist halt ein supergestelltes Problem
für diesen Film.
Also, ich glaube, dass,
jetzt mal ernsthaft,
wie oft ist der Fehler bei
Server hat Verbindungsprobleme
oder generell es gibt Probleme
mit einer Anwendung auf dem Server,
weil der Port auf dem Switch runtergefahren ist.
Das ist Putty auf Windows, ja.
Jetzt sehen wir hier,
dass der erste Port disabled ist.
Und um das zu beheben,
werden wir uns auf das Interface wechseln.
Genau.
Das heißt...
Alter, lass ihn doch mal machen, Mann!
Nico kann das ohne Probleme.
100 Pro.
Das ist easy as fuck.
Nico ist im zweiten, ja?
Nico weiß das wahrscheinlich
aus dem FF,
was er machen muss.
Du musst zuerst in den Modus wechseln.
Ja, lass ihn mal machen, Alter!
Wo du überhaupt Änderungen...
Boah, ey, der Ausbilder nervt mich.
...vornehmen kannst.
Das bedeutet, du musst
Configure Terminal.
Hat er doch schon, hat er doch schon.
T, genau. Sehr gut, ja.
So, und jetzt sind wir in diesem Modus
und jetzt wechseln wir auf dieses betreffende Interface.
Und jetzt haben wir No Shutdown.
Interface.
Und welches?
Das erste...
GI 0 slash 1.
Genau, das ist ein Gigabit-Interface.
Genau, G1.
So, jetzt befindest du dich auf dem Interface
und was machen wir jetzt?
Jetzt versuchen wir ihn wieder
freizugeben, oder?
Genau, und das Kommando, kannst du dich noch erinnern?
No Shutdown.
Ja! Sir, Nico weiß es.
Und das kannst du jetzt gleich sehen.
Hier siehst du bereits die Meldung.
Hier kommt das Interface wieder hoch.
Er hat eine Verbindung erhalten.
Jetzt mal an der Stelle.
Wisst ihr,
was in dieser Position
echt nice wäre?
So ein Rollwagen fürs Rechenzentrum.
Gab es früher in jedem Rechenzentrum
und haben die wahrscheinlich auch.
Oder mehrere.
Da konnte man einfach sein Notebook draufstellen
und musste nicht einhändig irgendwas rumtippen.
Wobei ich auch
oft zu faul gewesen bin.
Wir haben auch oft einfach auf der Erde gehockt.
Oder manchmal
hat auch einer gehalten und einer getippt.
Wir haben auch manchmal
einfach irgendwelche Kisten drunter gestellt.
Aber ein Rollwagen
wäre wahrscheinlich das angenehmste.
Und ja, hier siehst du auch
hier unten. Jetzt wird es grün.
Das kannst du jetzt erkennen.
Alter, Nico ist doch nicht doof. Das weiß Nico doch.
Siehst du?
Er hat aber nicht komplett gesüngt.
Jetzt kommt eine sogenannte Listening und Learning Phase.
Wo er sich
die Informationen, wo sich der Port
nochmal die Informationen
entsprechend austauscht.
Und die wird demnächst...
Also der Ausbilder geht mir auf den Sack.
Gut, man sollte das
jetzt auch nicht zu hart sehen.
Ich meine, sie sind sich sicherlich auch nicht gewöhnt,
dass man jetzt vor der Kamera möglichst kompetent
rübergehen muss.
Aber Nico hätte das easy
alleine in 5 Minuten gefixt.
Außerdem hätte Nico wahrscheinlich
nicht mal mit dem
Konsolenkabel drangemusst, sondern es wäre garantiert
auch remote gegangen.
Die Reporterin denkt sich nur, Alter, was
sehe ich hier gerade?
Ja, das denke ich auch für die Kamera.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem nervig.
In ein paar Sekunden wird die auf grün wechseln,
diese LED. Und danach haben wir
die Verbindung eigentlich wieder hergestellt.
Und kurz drauf müsste auch unsere
Fehlermeldung auf der Video-Wand
wieder verschwinden. Jetzt ist die Lampe
auch grün mittlerweile.
Jetzt ist der Fehler auch wieder behoben.
So, und wir haben jetzt genau
nix gelernt für das tägliche
Troubleshooting an einem Service,
der Probleme hat. Weil dieser Fehler
taucht in seiner gesamten Karriere
wahrscheinlich nicht einmal auf.
Das war auch einfach.
Die ganzen Abkürzungen, die du brauchst, die hast du schon relativ gut im Kopf.
Dir fehlt noch ein bisschen dann die
reinkommen. Die Lampe leuchtet grün.
Aber dafür ist ein Ausbilder ja auch da.
Okay, sie ist komplett
lost.
Wir sagen, dann
checken wir jetzt nochmal, ob sie auch drüben angekommen ist.
Genau. Sehr gut.
Tors, Tors, Tors, Tors,
Tors.
Acht Stunden für den Port hochfahren.
GG.
Die Problembehandlung haben wir richtig
gemacht. Es hat alles funktioniert am Ende wieder.
Das heißt, du hast die Tagesaufgabe
gelöst.
Nico hat keinen Bock mehr.
Nico ist
so fertig für heute.
Er hat gedacht, lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich habe keinen Bock mehr. Man merkt es richtig.
Damit ist eigentlich
dein Arbeitstag auch fertig. Das heißt, gleich das
Feierabend. Genau, Feierabend.
Er hat so keinen Bock mehr.
Für mich geht es weiter auf große Reise nach spannenden Superjobs.
Es hat mir richtig viel Spaß gemacht.
Demnächst
Post von Nico
auf slash Arbeitsleben
auf Reddit.
Was mich da erwarten
wird.
Es ist auf jeden Fall ein mega spannender Beruf.
Ich hätte auch keinen Bock drauf gehabt.
Richtig toll. Hat mich gefreut, dass ihr mich
da mitgenommen habt.
Deshalb muss ich jetzt trotzdem leider
tschüss sagen.
Okay.
Naja.
Man kann sich aus diesen Videos nichts ableiten.
Max jetzt vielleicht manchmal ein bisschen fies angehört haben.
Aber ich denke nicht, dass der Ausbilder
seinen Job schlecht macht. Und Nico
hat sicherlich deutlich mehr
als das, was er jetzt zeigen konnte in dem Video.
Weil der hat schon einen kompetenten Eindruck gemacht.
Ich glaube, der weiß es besser als der Ausbilder,
wie das funktioniert.
Was haben die acht Stunden gemacht, dass Nico so fertig ist?
Permanent den Ausbilder
und sogar noch die Personalabteilung
bei dir stehen haben, ist nervig.
Es gibt jetzt
hier bald, gibt es jetzt hier gleich den nächsten
Post von Nico demnächst.
Ich wurde gezwungen, einen Beitrag
für YouTube zu drehen.
Oder irgendwas.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch
auf YouTube? Zeigt mal her.
Ich habe übelst Hunger.
Chat, was meint ihr, was es
heute gibt?
Was gibt es heute zu essen? Wer weiß es?
Five-Fat-Time. Falsch!
Ha!
Es gibt keinen Lachs mit Nudeln.
Richtig!
Es gibt Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce
und Hackfleisch.
Korrekt. Es gibt da
bei mir immer abwechselnd. Entweder
gibt es Nudeln mit Lachs oder es gibt
Nudeln mit Tomatensauce und
Hackfleisch.
Und ab und zu mal abweichend.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Ne, das ist mir zu lang.
Was ist das?
Wie dieser minderjährige
Twitter gehackt hat. Das ist jetzt zu
harte Kost.
45 Minuten, ja ne, ist klar.
Was? Okay, Tim,
was gibt es? Hör auf,
Python als Programmieranfänger zu lernen.
Ne, wenn ihr mich fragt, ich finde zum
Einstieg tatsächlich Javascript mit am
sinnigsten. Wobei Python auch voll in Ordnung
ist als Einstieg.
Ich finde Javascript am sinnvollsten,
weil die Einstiegshürde, die mit
Abstand kleinste ist. Du brauchst
einen Texteditor und einen Browser. Also was, was
jeder schon auf dem Rechner drauf hat.
Okay, vielleicht nicht unbedingt
Notepad. Lieber
PHP.
No.
Oh Gott!
Nein, haben wir nicht.
Ey, Flutter als Einstieg finde ich nicht gut.
Es liegt aber auch hauptsächlich an Dart.
Mit Dart kommst du ja
nur wirklich nicht weiter. Außer mit
Flutter. Also wenn du Flutter machen willst, dann
ansonsten ist Dart komplett irrelevant.
Und ja, man kann auch die Leute gleich abschrecken.
Also ich denke,
dass Python sicherlich nicht verkehrt ist
zum Einstieg. Aber
aus meiner Sicht,
ich finde,
Javascript hat den einfachsten Einstieg.
Mal gucken, was der Tim dazu sagt.
Wir gucken das jetzt mal kurz.
Was sagt der?
Hör auf, Python zu lernen als Einstieg.
Hätte ich damals nicht so viel Zeit mit der falschen
Programmiersprache verschwendet, was
unter anderem auch Python
für mich war, hätte ich deutlich schneller und besser
Erfolge erzielen können. Daher würde ich dir in diesem
Video näher bringen, wie die falsche
Programmiersprache dich fast deine Karriere kosten
kann. Ey, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
übertrieben. Aber auch welche
Programmiersprache meiner Meinung nach
die beste für dich als Anfänger geeignet ist,
um schnell und gut Erfolge zu erzielen.
Als ich damals mit dem Studium angefangen
habe. Ich mein, C als Einstieg
ist eher so der
Oldschool-Joyce, ja.
Wenn du irgendeinen Lehrer hast, der früher mal Matheprofessor
war und jetzt Programmierunterricht hat, dann
wird's C.
Also heute zum Einstieg
ist Javascript
echt nicht verkehrt. Javascript, Python geht
auch. Kann auch C Sharp machen
oder Go oder Java
wie das beispielsweise an vielen Unis in Deutschland
so ist. Ist alles okay.
Aber von der Einstiegshürde
finde ich persönlich Javascript
am einfachsten.
Die Sprache ist nicht immer logisch,
aber mittlerweile
ist Javascript eine wirklich
gescheite Sprache. Javascript
hat es genau das Gegenteil von C++
geschafft. C++ wurde mit den
Jahren immer schlimmer und wirrer
und Javascript wurde mit den
Jahren immer besser.
...wurde mir auch in zwei Vorlesungen das Programmieren
beigebracht. Einmal in C und
einmal in Java. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt
richtig die gute Möglichkeit, besser im Programmieren
zu werden. Aber das sollte nicht
ganz so kommen. Eigentlich doch ganz einleuchtend.
Einerseits lerne ich in der Vorlesung
die grundlegenden Konzepte und andererseits
kann ich dann zu Hause in motivierter
eigene Regie diese vertiefen.
Doppelt hält schließlich... Java ist bestimmt auch nicht
verkehrt zum Einstieg. Außerdem habe ich ja immer einen kompetenten
Ansprechpartner, also meinen Dozenten
wenn ich mal nicht weiterkomme. Ich fing also an
mit 10 meiner Freizeit beizubringen via Udemy
aber dass das nicht gut enden sollte, das
habe ich damals noch nicht geahnt. Ich besuchte
also die Vorlesung und habe mir nebenbei den Kurs
angeschaut. Das hat am Anfang auch erstmal ganz gut
funktioniert. Die Programmiersprache, die habe ich jetzt auch immer
Stück für Stück weiter gelernt, aber
mittlerweile hat sich auch so ein kleiner Widerstand
in mir... Also, ich denke
ohne
Praxisbezug
wobei Praxisbezug ist das falsche Wort
ich denke ohne Projektbezug
ohne dass man was sinnvolles
wo man sieht, dass was rauskommt
macht
also wenn man nur Tutorials macht
ist das glaube ich nicht sonderlich motivierend
deswegen habe ich jetzt
ja auch schon öfters im Stream gesagt
das Beste, die beste
Motivation zum Lernen
beziehungsweise zum Vertiefen
ist dann immer noch, wenn man schon
was im Kopf hat, was man dann gerne
programmieren möchte
und daraufhin sich das Passende dann
raussucht
dann hat man irgendwie schon so
einen passenden Antrieb, weil nur Tutorials
sind halt übelst
lahm auf Dauer
ja deswegen ist
die Sache mit
Microcontroller auch nicht verkehrt
dann sieht man wenigstens
was, dann tut sich was
dann siehst du okay, wenn du anfängst
da blinken ein paar LEDs, später siehst du
ah guck mal, mein Microcontroller
lockt sich jetzt bei mir ins WLAN ein
da schickt sich eine IP
ich kann das Ding anpingen
ich kann vielleicht sogar eine Webseite
von ausliefern, wo ich irgendeinen Sensorwert
reinschreibe und sowas in der Richtung
da sieht man einfach
okay, da tut sich was
man hat immer auch mal wieder irgendwelche Erfolge
weil so ein wirklicher Erfolg
wenn man ein Tutorial
durch hat und dann am Ende
ja die Terminal Ausgabe
da steht wie aus dem Tutorial
so super motivierend ist das jetzt ja nicht
genau
Basteln ist die beste Motivation
ohne Typen lernst du
nicht Programmieren, hä warum
warum nicht, also die Logik
dahinter
wie du Schleifen machst, wie du irgendwelche Abfragen
machst, wie man
vielleicht irgendwie
Sachen abstrahiert und so, das lernst du doch auch
ohne dass du dich gleich, ich verstehe
mich, ich finde das ja durchaus sinnig
wenn man sich typisierte Sachen anguckt, aber
dass man jetzt mit einer
dass man jetzt mit Python zum Beispiel oder
Ruby oder so oder Javascript
nicht Programmieren lernen könnte
nur weil du nicht
direkt auf den ersten Blick irgendwelche Datentypen
hast, halte ich jetzt mal
für sehr gewagt
Dankeschön für den Sub, ich hoffe
ich hab nicht wieder
Leute vergessen
CheesyPro, POG Subscription
Runtime-Skripten lernst du
aber wie die Maschine
was, das verstehe ich
blicke ich jetzt nicht, was da
also ich mein, du magst vielleicht
wenn du, ok, ich glaube ich
ich glaube ich verstehe was du mir sagen
willst, ja
ok, wenn man Javascript im Browser
macht, dann weißt du vielleicht nicht
wie, was ein Register in der CPU
ist, ok, aber das
ist doch erstmal vollkommen irrelevant
das ist doch jetzt mal, wirklich
für den Einsteiger, ja, der
nicht gleich, der nicht gleich abgeschreckt
werden möchte
oder abgeschreckt werden soll
dem kann es doch vollkommen egal sein
ob der das weiß oder nicht
erstmal, und wahrscheinlich
der kann auch jahrelang
erfolgreich Software entwickeln
ohne sich jemals damit
auseinandersetzen zu müssen, was, wie, in welchem
Register auf seiner CPU steht
also
direkt, wer nicht gleich Linux Kernel
Patches kontributet
es geht da drum, dass man
gewisse Basics
lernt, und das ist die Programmiersprache
fast egal, man muss
sich überlegen, ok, wie teilt man
Probleme in kleinere Einheiten auf
man muss gucken, ok, wie
erstellt man sinnvoll
Kapsel sinnvoll Funktionen
wie macht man eine Schleife
wie macht man eine Triggerwarnung
IF Schleife, wie
macht man irgendwelche Abfragen
wie validiert
man irgendwie mal irgendeinen Input
nach und nach
das sind so Sachen, die sind auch komplett unabhängig
davon, ob du jetzt
irgendwie die Hardcore
Assembler Sache machst, wo das
die meisten Leute gar nicht drinne hinkriegen würden
und auch Fortgeschrittene nicht
oder das in Javascript
oder Python macht, ich weiß nicht
und falls wir jetzt auf den Unterschied raus
wollen, so zwischen Programmieren
und Scripten, ich persönlich mache da
gar keinen Unterschied, ich finde es auch bescheuert
einen Unterschied da drin zu machen, weil
es ist so fließend
und wenn schon überhaupt
muss man ja sagen
dass
jedes Scripten auch Programmieren
ist
Programmieren ist
wenn schon denn schon der Überbegriff
dafür, ich würde das
aber gar nicht mehr unterscheiden, weil
es sehr schwierig ist, heutzutage
es an irgendwie was Konkretem
festzumachen, nein, du lernst
Programmierlogik kennen, guck mal
ob du jetzt eine Schleife in Javascript
machst oder eine Schleife
in C, ist doch vollkommen
egal, wenn du
dir Basics lernst und ob
sich jemand wirklich mit manuellem Memory
Management auseinandersetzen muss
kommt ganz entscheidend
drauf an, was er machen will, wenn du jetzt
irgendwelche hardware nahen Sachen baust, wenn du irgendwelche
Microcontroller Sachen baust, ja, dann
ist es durchaus sinnvoll und dann ist es
auch sinnvoll, sich damit zu beschäftigen
okay, ist der ganze Mist
nach einem Funktionsaufruf wieder weg
wenn er fertig ist oder
bleibt das da, ja
aber ich gehe mal
ganz stark davon aus, es
wird einen großen Anteil
an professionellen Softwareentwicklern
geben, die sich damit auch
schwer tun würden und das ist doch gar
nicht so wild, wenn man es denn
braucht, kann man sich ja damit auseinandersetzen
aber das ist doch nichts, wo man die Leute
zum Einstieg irgendwie mit
quälen muss, die müssen wissen
wie sie ein If machen, die müssen wissen wie sie eine Vorschleife
machen können, so und wenn sie das
wissen, dann können sie das in C machen, dann können sie das in Go
machen, dann können sie es in JavaScript oder Python machen
auch wenn die Syntax ein bisschen anders ist
aber sie müssen zumindest erstmal wissen, okay
das brauche ich jetzt oder ah
ich sollte das vielleicht mal in eine eigene Funktion
packen und die und die Funktionalität
aufsplitten
dazu musst du nicht wissen
welche Register es auf einer CPU
gibt und irgendwie
ich verstehe schon, was du mir sagen willst
aber ich würde das gar nicht, gerade zum
Einstieg so gar nicht groß unterscheiden
und man kann das allgemein
gar nicht mehr so genau sagen, weil
nehmen wir jetzt mal Python zum Beispiel
oder nehmen wir auch mal JavaScript, es ist
eigentlich fast wurscht
du kannst beide Sprachen
sowohl in der offiziellen
Runtime laufen lassen
aber es gibt auch Python Compiler
und es ist im Endeffekt die gleiche
Sprache, das ist der gleiche Source Code
den du einmal mit dem Standard
mit der Standard Runtime ausführen
kannst, du kannst aber auch einen der ganzen
Python Compiler nehmen und da kommt tatsächlich
ein Binary raus, was ausgeführt wird
ich finde das ist fließend, aber ja ich verstehe
schon, was du mir sagen willst, ich würde aber die
meisten Anfänger damit erstmal gar nicht belästigen
deswegen finde ich auch JavaScript
durchaus sinnig
ja gut, das war ja nun mal voll für den Arsch
deswegen finde ich zum Einstieg JavaScript
auch durchaus sinnig, weil es die
Einstiegshürde, die ist halt einfach
nicht da, jeder hat einen Browser auf dem Rechner
jeder hat einen Editor
auf dem Rechner, wobei, also Notepad
hört man mal auf, also zumindest jeder
kann sich Visual Studio Code installieren
und kann anfangen, guck mal es streckt
jetzt nehmen wir mal
ein Beispiel, also
eines der allerersten
Programme, was Leute so machen
ist ein BMI Rechner
das ist so ein nahliegendes Ding
so, bitte geben
sie ihre Größe ein, bitte
geben sie ihr Gewicht ein und sowas
das ist so eines, das ist das
was nach Hello World kommt
so, und was
ist jetzt besser für
einen Einsteiger oder weniger
verständlicher und weniger frustrierend
er macht sowas hier
ich mach das jetzt mal so Pseudo
Pseudo mäßig, ja, also was ist besser
so, ein Einsteiger
macht sowas hier
keine Ahnung
value gleich
console readline
irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
keine Ahnung
wert eingeben
versus
wie geht das
scanf%
i
und
ich weiß
aus dem Kopf gar nicht, wie das funktioniert
und
macht man das so
ich weiß aus dem Kopf gar nicht, wie das funktioniert
ich weiß ja nicht
was da verständlicher
für ein Einstieg ist, ja
also wenn du mit Computer
programmieren meinst, dass man
irgendwelche
Assembly Befehle oder irgendwelche
ja, das muss tatsächlich
nicht jeder lernen
es sei denn, du möchtest irgendwelche
Microcontroller basteln
aber worum es mir drum geht ist, dass
sag mal so, Syntax
ist zweitrangig
du musst die grundlegenden Konstrukte
lernen, danach kannst du das
in C oder in Go oder
in Javascript oder in Python machen
ich auch nicht
keine Ahnung, ich würde den Unterschied auch nicht machen
doch
es ist wichtig, dass man es einfach lesen kann
was im Computer
passiert, ist doch komplett zweitrangig
für die meisten
Anwendungsgebiete
es geht da drum, ein Problem
aufzusplitten
in kleinere Logikeinheiten
und die dann mit der jeweiligen
Programmiersprache
gültigen Syntax umzusetzen
ob man dazu wissen muss, was
genau im Computer passiert oder nicht
halte ich mal ganz für
fraglich, es sei denn, es ist für
dieses Anwendungsgebiet wirklich relevant
ja, das gibt es
natürlich auch
dass das aus Performance
Gründen oder
aus
je nachdem, was du
machen willst, notwendig ist
spätestens wenn du Microcontroller programmierst
ist es oftmals notwendig
dass du das wissen musst
aber für die allermeisten
Anwendungen ist das glaube ich
ziemlich wurscht, ob du weißt
was genau passiert
jetzt mal ganz
im Ernst
nur mal als Beispiel
ähm
hab ich den Chat gelesen auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm, hab vergessen, was ich sagen wollte, alter Boomer
hier, ich wollte irgendwas
äh, fuck, alter
und umso mehr man drüber nachdenkt, was wollte ich gerade
sagen, umso weniger fällt es dir ein
ok, was, was, was
hab ich gerade gesagt, ok, es geht nicht
super einfach
ja, also genau, ich hab erzählt, dass das
meisten ja relativ egal ist, dass du das gar nicht unbedingt
wissen musst, es sei denn, es ist
für Performance Sachen wichtig
oder Microcontroller oder was auch immer man
das machen möchte
dann wollte ich irgendein Beispiel erzählen
warum das, ich hab keine Ahnung
mehr
wenn ich nicht mehr drüber nachdenke, da fällt es mir wieder ein
ja, das kommt
auch dazu, hätte ich mit C++
anfangen müssen, dann wäre ich jetzt
ja, Leute, die heute C++
machen, die
sind wahrscheinlich, auch wenn sie nicht ein bisschen weird champ
im Kopf sind, immer noch direkt weg
also du musst schon echt sehr
masochistisch drauf sein, um
Freude an C++
zu empfinden
manchmal kommst du nicht drum herum
beispielsweise, wo wir
haben im Stream ja auch schon ESP32
programmiert und sowas, teilweise sogar ein bisschen
Assembler dafür
da ist schon echt
immer ziemlich anstrengend
Rust und
ESP32 funktioniert nach wie vor
nicht richtig, ich wollte
ich wollte irgendein wirklich
nice Beispiel für das Erzählen
aber irgendwie fällt es mir jetzt nicht mehr ein
es geht nicht darum, dass es super einfach ist
also Lesbarkeit ist natürlich
wichtig, wir fangen jetzt
nicht davon an, Chat, wenn ich
davon jetzt anfange, dann mache ich den restlichen Stream
nichts anderes mehr
kommt auf
Branche und Region ein bisschen an
also wir hatten es letztens
davon, also so
genau kann ich dir das nicht sagen, vielleicht hat jemand im Chat
da ein bisschen mehr Erfahrung in dem Gebiet
jetzt auch gerade als Einstieg
also wir haben letztens mal das ausgerechnet
was mein Einstiegsgehalt
heute
also nach der Physioausbildung
was mein Einstiegsgehalt nach der Physioausbildung
heute wäre und ich glaube
wird das
nicht hier irgendwie
Inflationsrechnen, ja genau
heute wären das
45k gewesen
mein Einstiegsgehalt damals
ich habe damals 33.500
gekriegt und heute nach Inflation
wären das 45k
kann man sich jetzt daraus machen, was man will
ach so war das
gut, das würde ich
auch so sehen
wenn es dir darum ging
wenn es dir darum geht
zu lernen
was Hardware mäßig passiert
ok, ja
aber das ist halt für die meisten Anwendungen
gar nicht so
wirklich relevant, dass man das weiß
es gibt bestimmt genug Programmierer
die
seit Jahren
im Business Enterprise Umfeld
Java Software entwickeln
die können ja nicht
binary was addieren
oder so
und ob sie es müssen
ich meine, aus Interesse sollte man sich schon mal
ein bisschen damit beschäftigen
ok, wir gucken das Video mal kurz fertig
richtig breit gemacht
gegen Mitte des Semesters
hat auch jegliche Motivation verloren
ich habe den Udemy Kurs ganz klassisch
einfach beendet, aufgehört
aber manche Udemy Kurse sind auch übelst
langweilig
und in der Vorlesung, da habe ich auch nur noch so halbherzig mitgemacht
woran lag das denn nun?
einerseits daran
das muss an Java gelegen haben, Leute
eindeutig, oder? Verständlich
dass C für mich damals perspektivisch
einfach die falsche Programmiersprache war
und andererseits auch daran
dass sich der Udemy Kurs und die Vorlesung
einheitlich wiederholt haben
das war einfach nur langweilig und wenig stimulierend
letztendlich dann irgendwie die 20. Konsolenanwendung
umzusetzen, hat mich auch nicht mehr abgeholt
ich wollte irgendwie etwas mehr als
einen schwarzen Bildschirm mit weißem Text
irgendetwas greifbares, irgendetwas
ansprechenderes
und das schien mir mit C doch sehr, sehr weit weg zu sein
und ähnlich ging es mir dann auch
in der Java Vorlesung
ich wollte also anders an die Sache rangehen
ich nehme jetzt einfach eine pauschale, anfängerfreundliche
Programmiersprache wie Python
in dem ich verschiedene Projekte umsetze
ich habe mir also einen Udemy Kurs für Python
gekauft, in dem man speziell mehrere
Projekte umsetzen soll und habe
den auch nach dem zweiten Projekt abgebrochen
das waren wieder einfach nur Konsolenanwendungen
ganz viel Magie hinter
irgendwelchen Bibliotheken
ich hatte langsam das Gefühl, das Programmieren
viele Tutorials sind halt erstmal Konsolenanwendungen
das ist auch eines der großen
Vorteile von Javascript
du siehst relativ schnell was Grafisches
das ist gar nicht so richtig für mich
mittlerweile hatte ich auch schon verschiedenste
Programmiersprachen ausprobiert und keine hat mich so richtig
abgeholt, dass ich die ganze Zeit
nur gegen mich ankämpfen muss
das soll doch eigentlich nicht meine Zukunft sein, deswegen
programmier ich doch jetzt nicht
die Lösung dazu soll ich erst später finden
was ich dir letztendlich damit sagen will ist
lernst du am Anfang die falsche Programmiersprache
für dich, kann es dir das Gefühl vermitteln, dass du einfach
zu dumm zum Programmieren bist
du meinst, ey
wie hat er das
ausgesprochen
Azure?
so ganz merkwürdig
Microsoft Azure
hat er gesagt
Programmieren gar nichts für dich ist
für mich gab es dann aber eine Programmiersprache
hätte ich die von Anfang an gelernt
hätte ich bestimmt 99%
meiner Kommilitonen überholt
für mich war damals die Lösung, einfach eine Programmiersprache
zu wählen, mit der ich meine Vorstellungen
umsetzen konnte, egal ob ich
jetzt irgendwelche Apps auf Android oder IOS
programmieren will, ich sag auch Azure
Aufgaben via Skript automatisieren
oder mich auch einfach nur kreativ ausleben
will, am besten funktioniert diese
Programmiersprache auch noch auf jedem Betriebssystem
und das quasi auch noch von Haus aus
es sollte auch eine Sprache mit Zukunft
werden, sie sollte meinen Lebenslauf gut ergänzen
und auch in Firmen Einsatz
finden, ich weiß das sind eine Menge
Anforderungen, aber die Sprache die ich damals
auserwählt hatte dafür, die
könnte sogar noch mehr erfüllen, ich hatte mich
letztendlich für JavaScript entschieden
Beste, ja, ich würde
tatsächlich auch sagen, ihr habt es
jetzt von mir öfters gehört, ich finde
JavaScript ist zum Einsteigen echt
die beste Sprache
Einer der Sprachen mit der wohl niedrigsten Einstiegshürde
denn jeder Browser unterstützt sie
und du könntest sofort loslegen
außerdem war ich nicht eingeschränkt bei den Projekten
die ich umsetzen wollte, denn dank der ganzen
Frameworks war so gut wie alles möglich
Warum JavaScript?
Das Schöne an JavaScript ist
dass du sofort irgendwas siehst
wenn du einfach anfängst
Das ist glaube ich mit das Motivierendste was du
für Einsteiger machen kannst
und die grundsätzlichen Sachen
die du in JavaScript lernst
die bringen dir in anderen
Programmiersprachen ja genau sowas
und JavaScript ist
enorm vielfältig, du kannst
theoretisch mit JavaScript anfangen
und dein komplettes Leben
wo du eben in dem Beruf
arbeitest, JavaScript programmieren
wenn du willst
also ich glaube
es gibt fast nichts
außer vielleicht so wirklich
hardware-nahe Sachen wie Bootloader entwickeln
und sowas, vielleicht eher nicht
aber es gibt fast nichts
was du nicht in JavaScript irgendwie machen kannst
du kannst in JavaScript
Backend-Dinger mit
Node, Bun oder Deno bauen
du kannst Konsolentools
bauen wenn du willst
theoretisch, es gibt ja sogar
Microcontroller wo es JavaScript
Runtimes für gibt, wenn es denn wirklich sein muss
du kannst UI
Cross-Plattform UI Sachen
bauen mit Elektron und
Node zusammen
mag jetzt vielleicht nicht jedermanns Geschmack
sein, aber du kannst mit JavaScript
enorm viel machen und ein bisschen
Ahnung von Frontend-Entwicklung zu haben
egal wo du was du
hauptberuflich machen wirst
ist finde ich auch nicht verkehrt
ich meine ich bin hauptberuflich gar nicht
als Softwareentwickler tätig
und trotzdem
beschäftige ich mich ab und zu mal
mit Frontend-Entwicklung
also JavaScript finde ich nicht schlecht
und JavaScript hat das geschafft, habe ich ja eben
schon gesagt, was C++ nicht
geschafft hat, die Sprache kontinuierlich
über die letzten Jahre zu verbessern
C++ hat die Sprache
eher noch wirrer gemacht
sicherlich auch die
ein oder anderen Sachen, die gar nicht mal so übel sind
aber die gehen unter
im Wildwuchs
ja Go ist aber was das angeht bei weitem
nicht so vielfältig, ich meine mach mal eine Webseite mit
Go, also da wo Go
glänzt ist eindeutig
easy zu deploy, also easy deploybare
Anwendungen zu bauen, selfcontained
binaries
und
vielleicht noch so im Cloud-Umfeld
einfach weil sehr viele Tools
da schon in Go erstellt sind
ansonsten muss ich ehrlich sagen, bin ich nicht
so der wahnsinnige Go-Fan
wir haben sogar im Stream schon ein bisschen Go gemacht
und ich habe auch schon ein paar Sachen programmiert in Go
sogar ein
Command-Line-Tool, was wahrscheinlich heute immer noch
auf meiner alten Arbeit benutzt wird
aber ich bin kein
allzu riesen Go-Fan
meine persönliche Lieblingssprache, wisst ihr ja
ist Ruby
aber Ruby benutze ich
nicht mehr, das ist eigentlich hauptsächlich C Sharp
aktuell, ich mag C Sharp
auch wenn es Microsoft ist und auch wenn
Microsoft einem bei vielen Bereichen auf den Sack
geht, aber das kriegen sie
wirklich ganz gut hin
also ich mag C Sharp
ich mag mittlerweile auch wirklich
JavaScript, Go ist
auch okay, Go ist jetzt nicht, dass ich sagen würde
Go ist meine absolute Lieblingssprache
bin ich so scharf auf Go
C++ kann ich überhaupt nicht leiden
wenn man was in
C++ machen muss, dann weil man
keine andere Wahl hat
Qt ist tatsächlich eines der wenigen
eines der wenigen
halbwegs
erträglichen Sachen
in C++, aber auch nur
und es ist schon eine Weile her, wo ich damit was gemacht habe
aber auch nur, weil die
vieles selbst gestrickt haben
und das
intuitiver gemacht haben
als wenn man die Native
C++ Sachen verwendet
dann guckt euch mal
die C++ Standard Library
Collections an
und guckt euch die Qt Collections an
die Qt Collections, die funktionieren so wie man sie sich
vorstellt, die C++ Standard
Library Collections
ich sag nur Bool Vector
wo man sich so fragt
was ist mit den C++ Leuten los
das würde ich
auch so, ja, das sind auch zwei Sachen
die ich mir rauspicken würde, also generell
.NET und C Sharp und Visual Studio Code
das sind zwei Sachen, die Microsoft ganz gut auf die
Reihe bekommt. Ich würde sagen
GitHub ist auch jetzt nicht merklich schlechter
geworden seit der Übernahme
oder, was denkst du?
Oh, was hab ich denn da erzählt, zeig mal her
Offiziell bestätigt
nächstes Jahr wird das Jahr des Linux-Desktops
ja, so ist es
ich hab auch schon davon gehört
ja
ja, man sieht schon
warum
das sich nicht einfach verhält wie jeder andere
Vector, man weiß es nicht
ne, ne
kein Bock
ich müsste mal
allgemein wieder ein Youtube-Video machen, wird echt
mal Zeit. So, wir gucken jetzt endlich
das Video fertig, es sind noch zwei Minuten, Alter
eine Minute
er ist auch bei Javascript gelandet
oder Javascript
wie das die coolen Leute aussprechen
ich konnte damals damit extrem schnell
extrem viele Fortschritte machen
und es hat mir das Lernen
weiterer Technologien deutlich einfacher
gemacht. Ich denke also, Javascript
ist die beste Programmiersprache für Anfänger
weil du damit einfach fast alles umsetzen kannst
egal ob Desktop-Anwendungen, Handy-Anwendungen
irgendwelche Web-Servers
Skripte, vielleicht auch
Machine Learning und Data Science, naja gut, das
nicht ganz so sehr, aber es ist
trotzdem möglich und du lernst halt
einfach schon mal die Grundlagen des
Programmierens in einer spielerischen und
wenn du willst, auch in einer visuellen Art
und Weise. Na klar kannst du hier auch wieder auf
Konsolen-Anwendungen zurückgreifen, das ist
dir freigestellt und das ist ja gerade das Gute
da dran. Ich sag ja letztendlich
du wirst die Programmiersprache lernen, mit der du deine
Ziele umsetzen kannst und Javascript
ist da wirklich ein guter Startpunkt
aber selbst mit der richtigen Programmiersprache
kannst du am Anfang viele Fehler machen, die dich beim
Programmieren lernen aufhalten. Jetzt macht der Sellout
zum anderen Video, ja. Ne, wie gesagt
sehe ich ähnlich
Das Video haben wir geguckt, wo überhaupt
nichts drin rumkam. Oh Leute
ich hab Hunger. Motivation
Oh ne, das Video klingt
sehr nach
Comedy Gruppe. Wie kommt YouTube
auf die Idee, dass ich mir das angucken will?
Monatliches Einkommen bis
55k, ja, aus dem
Weg Geringverdiener, ja
Das vielleicht Unnötigste unserer
Zeit. Was?
Ambilight?
Ach ne
Ich dachte es geht um Fernsehen oder so
Kommst du nochmal on heute? Weiß ich noch nicht
Ich geh jetzt erstmal was essen
Ich hab übelst Hunger
Chat, gar nicht
Achso Moment, was
Was ist das?
Moment
Wie lang ist das?
Wait a minute
Wie lang geht der Kurs?
Über nen Tag?
Alter
Ein Tag und 7 Stunden
Also 31 Stunden
sind die
komplett von allen guten Geistern
verlassen oder was?
31 Stunden C++
Da musst du schon aber richtig
hart drauf sein
Da brauchst du das richtige Crimeset Mindset
Ja, genau
Du musst
mal so schissig genug
veranlagt sein dafür
Ich mein ich sag nur
Ach keine Ahnung
Ich glaub ich habs nicht mehr in der History
Ja auf
1,5% unter nem Tag
Nice
Okay Leute
Ich geh jetzt essen, ich hab übelst Hunger
Wir hören uns, machts gut, bis denn
See you